[Music]
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
doing
india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad the most prestigious team
chess event on the planet
in chennai the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
a top three seed in the open and the top
seed in the women's section the host
country has legitimate reasons to
believe it can sweep gold
the united states are the top seed in
the open section
fabiano caruana and team usa have come
to chennai saddled with heavy
expectations of gold or bust
norway has never meddled at the olympian
led by the best player on the planet
magnus carlson leads a squad looking to
change all that
while medals count
some accomplishments won't be measured
in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste dosto
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that
let the games begin
namaste welcome everybody to the opening
day of the 44th world chess olympiad
which is held in chennai india
and uh
really exciting day ahead
your host today will be two grammsters
i'm grand master arthur nations and that
is the legendary yasuo sermon himself
yeah sir
hello archers it's such a pleasure to be
with you and
welcome everyone as well on our coverage
it's a it's a great honor
absolutely and um
we are about to start uh to look at the
games which
is gonna take something like 10 minutes
maybe slightly less we have prepared for
you some very nice slides about the
format of the tournament who are the
favorites
so let's
let's i guess have a look right
absolutely
the olympiad format uh traditionally it
used to be
a round robin that was kind of
qualifying they separated the midsection
not so for the modern olympiads
um right right so uh as you see uh
here's the format of the of the
tournament um all federations in the
world kind of uh send the delegation i
believe this olympia yasser holds a
record right yes
by far i think they're looking at
more than 180
uh federations of teams from all over
the world and of course they also have
the feed a congress that's taking place
alongside the olympiad and this year's
p-day congress will also be an election
year for the presidency
we might get a new president or we might
stick to the old one i guess we're going
to talk about that at some point later
but about the teams about the teams you
see there are four players in the team
and that's what makes it really really
special i mean watch this olympiad is
not just a team moment it's a very
special gathering of
all the chess players in the world four
players and one reserved player exactly
at one time there used to be two
reserves players but they cut the number
of teams to five just as you described
and the reserve player
basically jumps into board four you
can't drop your first player and then
say to your reserve player go and play
on board number one so the reserve
player always comes in on board number
four and everybody's moved up
actually yes sir i still remember those
times because i think last time i was
playing myself in a olympic between
reservists it was 2006 to reno right
right so actually i'm quite quite happy
they changed that
yes yeah and i think it was 2006 or
eight they changed it
and um yeah that's that's what we have
um right now so i mean open tournament
i'm not really sure what was the year
yasser do you remember when they changed
it from the men's tournament to the open
tournament because the open tournament
allow also for the women players to
participate exactly and i have it in
mind it was 96 pardon me 86
and the olympiad in dubai but i could be
wrong we'll we'll rely upon our
streamers and chat uh to correct this
but the idea was that at a certain
moment the polgar sisters and
particularly judith
really really was an outstanding player
deserving to be in the world's top five
she qualified for the candidates as you
remember in san luis argentina in 2006.
so we say wait a minute i mean judith is
going to lead the olympic team from
hungary you know you gotta allow her in
the olympia so i think it was 86 but i
could be wrong and again i'll re i i
have our chat window open in twitch so a
big shout out to everybody's joining us
i'm gonna try my best to monitor
uh your questions and uh well we've got
so many people here to help us we've got
a real production team here at chess.com
i can't believe how many assets we have
and they're also going to be feeding us
top questions archers all right and also
they have prepared us very nice profile
for the team india who are the hosts of
the event this is truly historic moment
for india i mean
yesterday i was watching the opening
ceremony on youtube it was just
impressive you know i really really
regret i was not there
right so you joined i just enjoyed it by
watching the video and we have for you a
small video about team india
the host nation india also happens to be
the top seed in this year's women's
olympiad
surprisingly india has never meddled in
this event but the time to do so is now
with her top women's squad team a
2011 world championship finalist humpy
canero leads this team
she's the highest rated player in the
entire women's event
because canero will be favored in every
matchup team india's success likely
depends on a great result for her on
board one
but india's chances by no means end with
humpy
india has one of the strongest second
boards in the event as well harika
dronovali a three-time third place
finisher in the women's world
championship journal volley is likely to
be a key contributor to success in
chennai
vaishali rameshbabu is the third board
for india and is by far the youngest
member of india's top women's team
for playing board 3 vaishali earned some
bragging rights over her brother
pragnanda who plays a fourth board in
the open event
on this team the fourth board belongs to
commentator extraordinaire tanya sachdev
in fact sachdev has represented her
country in every olympiad since 2008.
in 2012 she even won the individual
bronze medal for her board
the experienced bhakti kulkarni
completes the tournament's highest rated
roster
a medal may be unprecedented but with a
squad this strong gold is clearly the
goal for india's women's team a
[Music]
so
yasser what do you think what how do we
properly evaluate india's chances to
take medals
i'm not sure we can predict them to be
winners of one of the categories but
clearly clearly india is looking towards
scored a major result here in in their
own olympia
no question about it arters uh you never
know how to exactly handicap these
things but you can talk about the trend
the trend is very very
favorable for india and their squad is
strong their women's team but don't
forget that as hosts
they get to play
a number of teams in both the open
section as well as the women's and uh
those other squads you can't take them
lightly either i mean they some of the
uh open juniors uh the junior players in
the open
i mean they're up and coming and they're
hungry i mean really hungry so uh
india
they're gonna score a lot of upsets now
having said all of that archers you know
it very well yourself uh
sometimes um the pressure on the hosts
are really really great and you can
underperform because you're so
i don't want to use the word frightened
or fearful but you're so nervous
about it
i imagine there's a tremendous stress
and uh yeah also
yeah for the first thing of india but
you know yasser i'm not really sure who
is going to perform better because also
the second team of india has a very very
strong lineup and i think even the world
champion magnus carlsen said
that he's more afraid of the second team
because there's
young players like domiraj yogesh prague
right
yeah impressive absolutely and uh just
talking about that pressure for just a
moment i mean there's no question
that uh viswanathan denand
deserves all the accolades we can keep
upon including being just a great
ambassador for this olympiad and
kind of the overall godfather if you
will of the teams and
to encourage
them
but he was also invited of course
if you look at his recent grand chess
tour results say the blair say hey vishy
why don't you come and play on the open
team and he politely declined because
again i think while he would perform
incredibly well
he just didn't want the pressure of
you know
performing
on his own home turf of chennai he would
much prefer
to give other players other promising
players the seat and that's what i mean
about the stress factor
yeah probably probably you're right uh
indeed a lot of pressure for indian
teams three teams in total for both
sections and here you see these are the
top ten seats and of course yes united
states i mean is this the strongest team
ever for united states in the history
by far it's not even close uh when i was
playing for the olympiad team i was like
top ten
and then we had two players
uh godakamsky and myself in the top 10.
but
we're talking about four players on the
u.s olympic team who are in the top ten
i mean it's an embarrassment of riches
right so you see
what the household names uh in the list
you see it's bobby corona lewanda ronnie
and wesley so
linear dominguez paris top 10 players
samuel shankland it's just incredible
and hikaru nakamura is not even playing
this year exactly and hikaru uh declined
his invitation to do a streaming we all
know what's going on there and our dear
friend john donaldson he was the best
man at my wedding is the captain a lot a
lot of pressure on the shoulders of the
us olympia team now talk about norway
for a quick second for us uh
norway uh coming in with high
expectations
right so norway obviously has the world
champion among wisconsin who has been
looking towards score a major result
here in olympia so far norway hasn't
scored uh any medals right he finally
said it correctly but this time this
time he has help ari and tari is
climbing to 27 congratulations
also he has tasted 27 concrete level
before then the young gun says
christiansen orcadal
this could be really a very good thing
to fight for the top three no question
about it and
these team events by the way team events
are very different from individual event
you just keep
uh
how do you say it
you keep your nerves you keep your calm
you
you really want to succeed not just for
yourself but for others for your
teammates and when you have a guy
holding down board one
and scoring the points like a magnus
carlsen
it lifts the whole team and everybody
starts gaining rating points it's like
it's like a
spirit
becomes an extra tension right yeah
everybody's making photos everybody
wants to see world champion right
right and you feel that and you get
caught up with it trust me on this one i
played in 10 olympia 10 olympic teams
two
world team championships and you get
caught up in that team spirit so getting
off to a very good start people
laugh about first rounds you know we
gotta walk over here or there whatever
they don't really tend to take it
seriously but trust me when i say the
teams are taking it seriously they want
that four zero score so that they do
play their top competitors as early as
possible
right uh so indeed this is a very
special gathering for all of the chess
players so in case dear viewers you
haven't really followed what is watchers
olympiad all about it's hell every two
years this is the biggest steam event in
the history of chess 44th edition
already uh is here due to pandemics we
had some changes we had the online
olympiad organized and finally finally
people have gathered basically what was
the last i mean i think it was in
batumi right so yes it's georgia
georgia 2018 yeah i played the yes
and then of course
right so i mean it really really feels
special also for the players to come
back greet familiar faces uh play in
this uh spectacular atmosphere you know
yasser i looked at some of the pictures
coming from chennai i'm i'm just stunned
really i'm just stunned
so this opening ceremony was just
awesome then they have this chess bridge
did you see that that you know that
bridge
as as a just just uh coloring right
well i mean i've got something to look
forward to there i saw a graphic of the
early kind of 2000s and that the olympia
was being dominated by two countries in
particular the ukrainian armenia from
2004 to 2012
those two countries were winning the
gold and uh
really uh
quite a surprise i would say of course
armenia
um would it was always one of the top
seeds but once again what i had said
earlier really applied lavon aronian
he was the anchor of the team and he
dragged those players with
the gold medals and you know lavon
played out of his mind in some of these
olympia it's really really impressive
not to take away any of the performance
of the other teams but i'm just saying
those gold medals uh you know you can
really chalk up to uh what was happening
on boards one and two of course you also
see there's a very nice key factor for
which might contribute to the success of
ukraine armenia it's the great team
spirit
and armenia and ukraine they have an
awesome team spirit and this is probably
going to be a key element because it's
not a single event it's just not enough
to play good chess you also have to
sometimes make small sacrifices for the
team for example you have slightly
better position team needs to secure the
victory or a draw so you you basically
sacrifice your result for the team so
the team wins
and uh maybe norway could have really
good team spirit among of all other
teams so yeah
and then and then you saw the more
recent the last five editions there
where uh china you talk about team
spirit and in 2016 the us wins but i
just want to say that that kind of
belies the reality of what actually took
place i was there in batumi and i was
there at the last
one of the last games eli
elianov has won
for the ukraine and literally on the
stage the ukrainian team just jumps in
one another's arms in a gleeful
uh victory dance i just don't feel like
it was a victory jump
victory jumping as they thought at
precisely the moment elia eliana won
they had won the gold
wow it wasn't until like some result on
board i don't know 30 or whatever it was
uh john donaldson could give you details
uh
the gold medal was decided there the u.s
won so it was by a fraction of a
fraction
that we won so sometimes these olympiad
scores and results but then russia
russia
the number one seeds who had been
underperforming
for so long have started to perform
really late
recently and winning the open scores and
of course in the ladies section well uh
the women's teams from china just so
strong ukraine china russia georgia i
mean all the traditional favorites and
now this olympiad with
with uh china russia missing india says
wait a minute you know
we turned a shot here right yeah
our turn
our turn we are going
exactly there you see some of the nice
uh results also i just want to say that
the olympiad
is obviously a competition and we really
want to say what a great competition it
is but i really want to cubby hold that
for a moment and just stop thinking so
much of the olympiad as a competition
it's really more a spirit of friendship
and
meeting people and teams from all over
the world and it's not just teams from
all over the world it's organizers who
are coming and saying
in the bundesliga i have this team and i
would love for you
prague
to join our team and i come to invite
you personally and i am the organizer
deal
and it would be wonderful for you to
come and visit our tournament in
switzerland so you get organizers you
get arbiters you get captains
and
coaches and trainers and then you have
your collectors and then of course the
fee day meetings and throughout all of
this you're taking pictures with
everybody
you you're on a bus
and i'm not joking you're on a bus and
they're taking photos
and a lot of handshakes right a lot of
handshakes haven't seen you for a while
okay yeah exactly exactly exactly and
then of course you have those worst
moments
archers you know what i'm talking about
the people come up to shake your hand
and it says they're saying to you it's
wonderful to see you again it's i
haven't seen you in ages and you're
looking at the person saying please god
what is their name
this has happened really yeah
right
and of course
now we're waiting for uh the games to
begin but
as soon as we get our transmissions and
what are we going to do in terms archers
of looking at games there's so many
games we have to limit ourselves
yeah so what i propose obviously we want
to look at uh perhaps what are the
pairings for the round one so here you
see it's obviously india india is
actually going to play on board one i
think the reason is that they have
special dedicated cameras obviously for
all indian fans they're playing zimbabwe
i don't think zimbabwe is very unhappy
to be honest no
no they get to be featured in the
olympiad how sweet it is
right and then we have team united
states of america playing against angola
also a big moment for mongolians
lebanon against norway magnus castle is
resting today and actually this is not a
big surprise like
yes sir that
the leaders of the teams they sometimes
skip the first round or the second round
and they give a chance for the other
players to compete
exactly i think uh for the team captains
it's kind of nice to put the reserve in
and just to kind of get a gauge of how
the reserve is doing also i want to say
that oftentimes board one is missing
on day one game one uh from jet lag
don't forget uh
is a quite a trip it's a journey
and a lot of the players may be
switching time zones of
four hours and a lot more
what's the really the preferred time to
arrive to a tournament so that the jet
lag passes away is it something like two
or three days
it varies from most people for me i'm
terrible i've always been impacted
incredibly negatively by jet lag and a
lot of the scientific studies i've read
have suggested one day per hour so if
you're going to go
somewhere which has a two hour time zone
difference you're going to go there two
days early
if i'm going to india i might have a
nine hour time zone difference from say
if i live in seattle right
so i'm sitting there going but i can't
go nine days early i just can't
why not it's impossible i mean i stay in
the hotel for nine days so i get
uh you know on a
on the right normal
hour that's just that's just tough i
remember playing
one time in a tournament in lugano
switzerland i was coming from seattle
and
though it was the flight from hell
missing connections everything it was
really really really terrible
long story short i arrived 24 hours late
so literally uh the the organizer picked
me up at the train station in lugano and
took me to the game
wow that's it right right
uh on on game seven
i woke up literally at the board and i
was playing victor corchadoy for first
place
and i have no recall of what happened in
the first six games that's there that
was terrible it was like i finally you
know arrived you know and i was like
what am i doing playing victor on
boardwalk
like what what happened before right
what happened before it was like
it was like a blank so i've always been
hit by jet lag very very hard
and others are less affected how about
yourself archers did you feel impactful
by china well i can't really cross so
many continents i flew once to
australia wants the united states oh
sorry twice yeah usually i recover very
quickly
okay um
right
so yeah i mean
i would say i arrived something like two
days before they started tournament and
i think most of the pl most of the
players in india have done that i know
my
team latvia which i'm not playing this
year they arrived um actually two and a
half days before they had a rough um
schedule to get there they're there
they're playing they enjoy everything
so yeah today should be enough
cool and of course again everybody just
bear with us we've had a lot of teams a
lot of assets i want to say on the
ground in india and
as you could expect in day one uh with
so many games we are now getting uh the
transmissions and i see we've got angola
usa uh on board one
and uh the angolan players are clearly
going to be terribly overmatched but
that doesn't mean our turn that you
can't play good openings
that doesn't mean you can't enjoy the
game right exactly enjoying it big time
yeah you can compete
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
for them to play against some of the
best players in the world i mean
obviously wesley so
requires no comments and i think miguel
sergio is gonna enjoy it and he's gonna
fight
yeah uh and i remember in 1986 i had the
olympia
of my life like seriously it's not a
joke i beat everybody i was like plus
six on board one
and uh the
early in the tournament uh we had a very
easy
match with india very easy match
everybody expected that we should score
4-0
and i was playing this young
punk
kid
on board one a certain viswanathan
denand
everybody was winning very easily their
games
somehow there's this guy on board one
who by the way he played the whole game
in like under an hour it's just
unbelievable what speed he played he had
me on the ropes
or was the whole game i escaped
with a draw and uh you know like
everybody said who who was the shia nun
so a lot of these teams
do have
that one player who is extra extra extra
historic extraordinary
and it's sometimes it's not easy to get
those 4-0 results because you have a
eugene torre
from the philippines on board one
you know and eugene was eugenia was
tough
i think it's a good strategy team
strategy to include some of the best
youngsters in the team because sometimes
i mean when you check the lineup they
have they have the best juniors in the
country under 20 they give them a chance
they give them a shot to fight for
something
and we have seen many breakthroughs
especially in the olympia and probably
one of the most famous examples which
jumps to my mind is vladimir kramnik's
performance in 1992 manila olympiad okay
that's ancient history really right but
he just made uh headlines after his
amazing start
no question about it that was of course
the olympiad where garrett juan gary
kasparov said i will play for the soviet
team
if vladimir is included and
he really rubs some of the officials
wrongly because vladimir
wasn't supposed to be included and he
had a great result i in fact got
victimized by vladimir so what happened
was when team usa played the soviet
union unfortunately gary kasparov
destroyed godikamsky
and i felt this extra pressure
against vladimir kramnik that i should
win
in order to equalize the results and
unfortunately vladimir was largely
unknown
he had offered me a draw he had offered
me a draw of i guess around move 20 hit
equalize but i i continued and lost
and it's just one of those things where
the olympiads really not only they bring
out the best performance
but when you include the youthful that
young energy it can be magic and
vladimir kramnik as you rightly pointed
out in 92 had a gold medal performance
right and uh talking about the team
strategy i guess this is more visible in
the later rounds but at least when i was
playing in the olympia like i played six
olympias myself for team latvia usually
we have a very basic strategy what wins
black draws so it's so simple so you're
playing more or less an equal opponent
uh who is competitive
draw draw it black is fine right so it's
really like an effort which matters
yeah and it's strange today we don't
well in those old days uh they used to
have adjournments and the games were
much much longer now there's no germans
of course
but in the old days you would actually
have these kind of team strategies where
the captain
would often interfere and the one
captain would go over to the other
captain and say you know i don't know
about you but i think uh we're winning
on board one and we're losing on board
three
uh the other two games are rather even
what would you say about four draws
and the captain suddenly would make four
draws like like literally you're winning
on port one
captain said look we're losing on board
three so two two result and that's a
very good result
i don't think they do that so much these
days but in the old days the captains uh
really interfered
but you know i think yes and also
players definitely feel what's going on
and i definitely recall one of my last
experiences i was playing in 2016
olympiad for team latvia we playing
against hungary so hungary was
richard
roberts yeah a very very strong team
2750 first board couple of 2650s i was
playing with board three and what
happened is that on board one sheriff
beat robert bore to igor kovalenko beat
i think ference berkash i know both were
lost
and and we are we are supposed to
already win the match so we lead to one
in the score and i'm playing with white
i have an extra pawn so this is where
the team resolved team strategy kicks in
instead of trying to play for the win
just play for the draw
and my opponent tries to win obviously
right he tries to win but he can do
nothing and that's how we won the match
right so this is just one of the
examples that the team result is very
often of uh utmost priority
absolutely and you have to feel that as
an individual uh as we get ready for uh
actually looking at a lot of the games
we're just gonna go uh for a quick break
our tours what do you say yep let's see
you in couple of minutes so the game
should be running up in a moment don't
go anywhere the the olympic is just
starting see you soon yeah baby
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is elwood dawson i'm from
chicago i'm sika blackman my name is
roberto beza junior and what i want to
share is i love tacos tacos and chess
[Music]
with the chess program really even chess
in general like on the deck
you uh
you kind of lose yourself you don't
really think about your case
you learn to think differently you know
you strategize more
i sometimes come out
uh 7 30 in the morning i'll probably
play until lock up you know so it makes
my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk
it's it's crazy you know like the chess
players we got our own little circle you
know and all of us play each other we
talk trash about who be who who garbage
yeah i never play that dude again he
garbage i have a plan
but yeah it's real competitive
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everybody from the
broadcast of the 44th international
world chess olympiad in chennai india
yasser sereban and i'm arthur nations
we're going to be your host for today's
round one of the olympiad and we are
getting ready some moves yes sir
excellent uh is very nice of course on
day one on olympiad we have to
understand that everything that can go
wrong
will go wrong so we're going to do our
best to make sure that we can
go through as many games as we can
but on the other hand we have to
understand we've got issues and we'll
work through them
india
versus zimbabwe i see that we've got uh
a game here 8284 by white
do we check how this game actually
started from the moment
right
so what we can do is we can follow the
games which are actually being relayed
right now because obviously like yes
already said they want sometimes there
are technical issues i mean
so this is one of the games we see right
now
oh d6 what what is that aren't you
supposed to play d5 here yes that's the
main line with both captures on d5 as
well as e5
i think it's called the floor mckenna's
variation by the way this was my bread
and butter that i mean i furnished an
entire apartment
winning games from this variation and i
had included victor korchnoy and john
timmer
amongst a whole long line of victims i
and i would play 3e5 so the move d7 d6
uh a little too passive for my taste
right e5 and switch to the to the
english opening right
yeah but i'm saying after e6 e4 i think
the move d7 d6 is a little too passive
okay it's slightly passive black gives
away the space advantage usually one is
very cappy
very happy
so we have some sort of kings inning
with the loss of a tempo e6 e5
uh this is actually interesting
interesting approach by video because
he's not closing the uh structure we
don't move something like d5 which is
right going up common approach against
kings india yeah although this is not
kings in and is it i mean what what is
this really this is an old indian uh so
a king's indian is of course with a
fianchetto on the kingside g7 g6 and
bishop g7 the old indian they put the
bishop on e7
uh in the kind of a style
that said they want to keep their
flexibility often black just put his
rook on the e8 and the bishop back on f8
but uh again this loss of tempo
that's a no-no
um
all right i mean black is not doing
terribly of course a5 a4 yeah you
already mentioned yeah so this is a
mysterious slightly more weakening the
b4 square absolutely
i guess in some old books it would be
slammed this is a terrible move right
you weaken the b4 square you weaken the
c power square but with the development
of the modern engines they say hey this
is an awesome move
the other
point i don't know about awesome that's
pretty good
awesomely bad uh yes a4 as you mentioned
and that is the key
thing that you said it weakens the b4
square now if that knight on d7 could
magically
drop on to the b4 square then it's okay
but
now the move a2 a4
without the knight coming to b4 isn't
that terrible but the difference of
course it's all about you're not able to
play b3
three b four ponderously slow of course
but you can deny
black the c5 square as well uh what has
happened uh after bishop e after a4
sorry
after four i believe there's no more
moves at least we're not receiving any
more moves i see might as well be played
10 moves
i don't really know but that's the
position we have
uh
yeah so with it is enjoying his space
advantage i guess he's not going to play
d5 anymore is he now
no i think he's just going to play rook
d1
and put pressure on the e5 and
oftentimes
if you're and this is very important if
you're going to play the move a4 you're
probably going to go bishop to a3
in order to put pressure on the d6 pawn
just as you've
shown it there and again to our audience
a big shout out thank you each and every
one of you for joining us and sharing
your day with us we're going to do
our best to navigate around the various
boards and we probably want to go
through as many games as we can but we
can't always promise you that we'll be
able to show you
the matches because again day one a lot
of
glitches can be expected but we're gonna
have fun
regardless we have some games actually
it's not so bad because the next game i
see it's game number 10 which is a
different team
let's do it or maybe let's jump in so
that we have actually some
uh positions on the board that is one of
the norwegian chess players johann
sebastian christensen who is actually
nicknamed by bach as far as i know
between his friends
and sebastian bach right i like it i
like it yes uh we have here in holland
our own
benjamin bach
spelt differently b-o-k
and not
b-a-c-h but uh big
ben right
so that we have a symmetrical english oh
sorry i think i
i think i jumped somewhere all right
here we go that was king's indian was it
no not kings india
banco gambit banco
yes sir what is your relationship with
the bank of gambit is it a playable
opening
up to what level can you play
very very difficult uh my experiences
have been with the benko gambit
first of all i think it's a superb
weapon as black for swiss events in
swiss events you simply have to score
80-90 percent to win a decent price
which means you can't just rely upon
winning with white
and drawing with black you got to win
with black and to my mind
you
when you make a gambit with black you're
risking your life
because you're uh your reply behind
but the bengal gambit is one of those
extremely rare gambits that you can play
as black
and you have
not just dynamic play you have long term
strategical play it's an extremely
unusual
gambit that i think is
totally totally valid i played it as
black myself i do much better on the
white side than i do the black side and
i remember
playing with her against valerie sala
valerie salaf a famous grandmaster from
the soviet union he actually became the
number three player in the world at one
time behind this far off in karpov
but i chose to play against valerie
saloff but benko because he
he i couldn't find any games of his
where he had played against it
then it turned out that uh
it was valerie's favorite weapon as
black
no that's a problem
it was like i was trying to surprise him
today you would open chess space
obviously you would also check what your
opponent is playing also in the other
color right i mean exactly
we've made a draw so i mean somehow i i
i managed to escape with my life but i
remember uh surprising my opponent
that went terribly wrong here we see
some wonderful
uh camera feeds from the olympiad and by
the way i always as a player look to see
that
that the players have rooms on their
boards in other words they're they're
not elbow to elbow or jowl to chow but
they could you know breathe and it looks
very good the playing hall there you see
there's plenty of space to for the
players to walk around
the games yeah there's there's a huge
call indeed but this particular game
yesterday i think we chose not a very
good example because i'm fairly sure
that the last move knight c6
was as much time for sacrifices
that was not played pretty sure it
wasn't played so i'm gonna simply make a
real
error please
i'm gonna simply switch to sam shanklin
one of the united states players we do
have
we do have a game from sam against um
uh dominguez junior
okay i'm hoping
from that uh
look there that uh
sam was on the black side
um yeah sam is playing with white we
should be the masculine
okay
this brings warm feelings to my heart
really because i've played mass coverage
in so many so many years
okay
yeah 97 very aggressive i mean 97 is
usually the aggressive approach bishop
d7
is the positional approach
all right and c3
what wants to grab the center
right
i see in a lot of times after this
middle c3 that the games almost seem to
transpose into what looks to be anyway a
really low pass
the bishop ends up on c2 the pawn ends
up on d4 and it looks like that you
goran rui lopez
for example something like this right
save
yeah a6 a4 maybe d5 at some point and
actually that on d7 is feeling rather
well because usually it's stuck
somewhere
yes
precisely so it looks a lot more
flexible on d7 than on a5 oh
right
so bishop d3 this is slightly mysterious
move but uh that's actually one of the
common ideas what wants to have the
bishop here in c2 to protect the pawn on
e4
then push d4 and 95 is a very very
committal move from black which engines
don't really
support
but uh it's difficult for what to break
through
okay
uh we'll go quickly through this
position and we'll just take a quick
break we're gonna need to refresh
our transmissions archer and just make
sure we get all of the games or as many
of the games as we can so apologies to
our audience just take a quick break and
we'll be right back
see you soon
yes indeed
[Music]
do
we're
we're back uh from the welch's olympia
providing the coverage of round one as
you see there's some minor technical
issues coming from the
site uh provided by the organizers
because not all of the games are coming
true however we do have one game of
samuel shank against junior dominguez
being played right now your hosts today
are going to be uh yasser servant and
i'm gramstraton actions
yeah and again arthur's uh great to be
with you uh nice to be calling the games
alongside you there and as we uh dropped
out there i see them on it
as we dropped out there i was saying i
was hoping that sam shanklin had the
black pieces and when you said well you
have the white pieces and you were
saying knight to e5 i like
black's position
in the current situation despite the
double pawns in the center i don't care
what the engine says about the move 95
but
uh i think black has solved
99 of his opening difficulties in the
current position
yes things are not going to be easy for
samuel and while we are about to go back
to the game i believe our producers have
prepared a very very nice video about
the team usa
you should see
with a couple of powerhouse countries on
the sidelines team usa is the popular
choice to take gold at the 44th olympiad
blessed with a talented roster led by
fabiano caruana the top-seeded americans
are looking to secure gold as they did
four olympiads ago back in 2016.
that gold medal was historic for the
united states as it was the first gold
for team usa since 1976
a drought that spanned across five
decades
loaded with olympiad experience caruana
and wesley soh were both key
contributors to the gold medal team in
2016.
even one of the newest members to team
usa levon aronian is no stranger to
competing at the olympiad ironian bagged
gold while representing armenia during a
stretch in which that country won three
gold medals across four straight
olympiad appearances also making his
team usa debut in chennai is lanier
dominguez considered to be one of the
strongest players ever to come out of
cuba dominguez rounds out a team usa
roster with few weaknesses coached by
chess.com commentator robert hess team
usa's roster is so deep that reserve sam
shankland would likely play first board
for most countries in this year's events
as expected caruana leads team usa as
the first board but even with a gold
medal already under his belt fabi heads
into this olympiad with plenty of
motivation
coming off his clunky finish at the
candidates tournament fabby will need to
find his game for the us to realize its
potential as the favorites
during its triumph in 2016 team usa was
led in scoring by wesley soh
in this year's olympiad so returns to
play as the two seed which should offer
him some favorable matchups the three
seed is aronian which also should play
in team usa's favor
aronian ranked as the top player for
each of armenia's gold medals in 2006
2008 and 2012. aronia now brings that
experience and pedigree to team usa
while going up against the opposing
country's third best player
carrying three of the top ranked players
at the 44th olympiad while facing a
significantly weakened field of
countries the united states is well
positioned to come away from india with
just its third gold medal since 1937.
the time for team usa is now
well that was a lovely profile wow it
was just stunning i mean how do you stop
team usa at all i mean they're just huge
favorites in this tournament
true true but uh just looking at that
history it was kind of funny i i just
had to smile
you go back to 1937. and the gold medal
in those days uh
the teams from the soviet union didn't
play
and i remember they had these uh
cable matches and when the united states
first played
against the soviet team by telegram or
telex
it was a shock
to america when we lost
i mean the soviets said like badennis
we had like reshefsky and charles calmey
i don't know nicholas ross i mean we
were really really over matched we
couldn't believe that we lost then in
that
clip that profile we were told and uh
yes is true in 1976
we have won
the olympiad in tel aviv israel which
was a very
uh
funny
uh situation so first of all we very
barely won it we squeaked out ahead of
holland i don't know if it was tie
breaks but
the crazy part was if you go back to the
70s
the feeder was dominated by the soviet
union that is to say their general
assembly
so you had these socialist nations
and it very
much reflected it was a mirror
reflection of the united nations and in
the united nations the soviets in the
general assembly had the votes full stop
in the story so there was israel
who had put in their bid to
win the olympiad or to host the olympiad
and everybody understood that israel
would never
be able to host the olympiad i mean
politically it was impossible full stop
all the arab nations for example would
vote against israel et cetera et cetera
and somehow it was a secret vote
and
tel aviv won it was like what
nobody couldn't believe it
and
literally like half the nations
immediately boycotted included including
the soviet union did not send teams to
the olympia
and so it was a really really reduced
olympian and i think they even had a
counter olympiad somewhere else to try
to
take away the prestige of the olympia
from israel
and so we very barely squeaked by and we
wanted and in the modern era
for us
we were so so happy to win the golden
baku i mean individually we've always
had great performances i i've won gold
medals as an individual and we've won
you know bronze medals and silver medals
and stuff like that but you know winning
the olympia is really really hard and
like i said
uh in baku we just barely got past
ukraine ukraine thought they had won it
right yeah ukraine usually as we already
discussed have a great team spirit
fantastic usually perform very very good
in olympia's also european team
championships right
so yeah you know yes sir i remember what
was it i think it was fabi who said it
during the candidates tournament he was
asked about uh the prospects of the
olympiad how he treats united states uh
chances win the tournament he said
basically okay anything but not winning
will be disappointing it's just quite
understandable right
because again i mean we're coming in
with
really what i would say is a monster
squad and you mentioned in that
wonderful profile big shout out to
chess.com and the producers for that is
i said look you know lanier dominguez
is the greatest cuban player
since jose raul capablanca full stop
and i mean that guy
is incredibly good he would be first
born for
any country uh
in this olympiad
very easily and you know sam shankle is
the same and lavona rhodium he led the
armenian team so you could take our
first three players i think wesley and
lavonne and
probably
shake them up and whoever came out one
two or three
that's good enough
you know lanier i think would be very
happy
to say okay you three guys determine the
first three boards i'll take i'll anchor
four and uh
yeah it's just what what can i say this
team
of the united states is awesomely strong
and there's going to be a lot a lot of
pressure on their shoulders i can tell
you a lot of pressure i think so there's
indeed a lot of pressure because when
you are a huge favorite between the
tournament uh they their rating gap
average rating gap from the second seed
it's about 75 points that's huge wow
right so you feel this pressure you feel
that you have to prove it all of them
are hard and professionals the best
players in the world however i mean
still it might just take one match one
misstep against direct competitors and
that's it so they know the stakes are
high here exactly i'll go back uh pardon
me for harping on this point but i'll go
back to baku for just a moment
and in the last round i mean canada
coming out of nowhere just nowhere
canada i can't tell you where they came
i don't from directly where they came
from they beat latvia in the previous
round yeah i i was playing and i lost oh
i know where they came from
well
king canada
comes to board one in the last round
against the united states out of nowhere
and it's sort of like oh my gosh the
gold medals are at stake for us
and for team canada like this is like
one of their greatest performances ever
full stop
and sam shanklin lost
loss to eric hansen
and that was like that could have cost
us the gold medal and just like you said
i mean if if sam shanklin makes a draw
on that game there's no discussion about
it we we win the gold medal absolutely
100 for sure sam loses that like one key
critical game and suddenly tie breaks
galore
you know
it's like oh dear
uh what what game do you have on the
board i see this very interesting kings
indian with white having a knight on e4
yeah what what is that game
it's some sort of a king's indian i
don't know one of the games relay that
is incoming maybe we can very quickly
check
maxwell yeah he is one of the brightest
young stars from iran
very strong 27 congress already
yep
i believe he was uh
training um i mean he was working on
chess something like 10 or 12 hours per
day which is just
about 10 or 12 hours more than i do
usually
you got that right
i was never really what i would call a
professional uh i worked with victor
korchnoy for about 18 months
and there was probably a 30-year age gap
between us and he exhausted me
like i didn't know what working on chess
was until i worked with victor korchnoy
he
worked 10 hours a day and i probably
worked two maybe
three
uh
i was just doing too much uh other
things uh but yeah when uh the iranian
player you just mentioned said in an
interview that he's working
eight ten hours a day i just went i mean
it was eight yeah wow
[Laughter]
that's hard work i gotta tell you
because working on chess
it's a very very individual sport so you
really need this motivation this you
have to feel it inside you like okay
let's look at another position
and nothing is difficult as working on
your endgame muscles so you you see all
of these rook and pawn end games that
you just have to know inside and out
like you just have to
assume
you're going to get a rook and pawn end
game where you're pawn down
and it's an armageddon game you really
have to imagine that you're black you're
upon down and you know it's a
theoretical draw and you have to just
play it like in 15 seconds with absolute
understanding
and playing online doesn't really count
no
if somebody somebody is watching this
and thinks oh but i am training like
four or five hours a day on chess.com
this is i mean for fun you have to
understand that right that's just that's
just exercising some kind of tactical
muscles that's not a technique that you
you want to learn but once you do that
and you say okay i've mastered this
position absolutely i got it
then you say okay now i'm ambitious
let's go to the next one give me another
rook versus pawn ending
and let me master that again i'm seeing
some really really nice uh camera
views from the playing hall and i'm
looking at the players walking around
and i'm not seeing a crowded hall
so i'm thinking the players are really
happy
i i think i i saw the call in the
pictures it's huge so it can fit in a
couple of thousand people
wonderful so it's not divided like in
batumi at the last olympia that was
being held on site we had two halls
right it was still great but i mean you
you could feel that this unity of
everything under the same roof is
missing
and now i mean the indians have provided
this amazing call
and uh it looks great
yeah this vishy vishy and we had done an
interview with him on
the grand chess tour and he
was explaining that he was so pleased
with the hall that they had found in
chennai he said it's going to be a great
playing all the players are going to be
very happy i'm looking also and i'm
seeing a nice area for the spectators to
just to be walking around against the
walls of the playing hair area and as
opposed to being in some fixed
seated auditorium looking at big screens
they can actually walk around the plane
hall so it looks
to me
first day and you know lots of things
can happen
but it looks to me that it's really
really cool really well at the moment at
the moment this is uh for some of the
games the only way how we can see them
right how they can see them
exactly most of the games are
unfortunately not coming true we do get
some of the games not all of them they
are probably going to be fixed not our
fault but we can focus on what we see
and this is the game i'm not sure we
really should focus on it too much but
we start to talk about these kings and
then
uh some weird stuff to be honest i'm not
sure how to combine together b4 with
rookie you want but i guess chess allows
everything yeah the the bayonet attack
uh b2b4 was at one time really if you go
back instead of the move knight h5 was
was really criticized as not
a good move because of a5
uh how are we doing in terms of analysis
can we make moves uh
yeah we can make most what what kind of
move would you like to make a5 a5 yeah
of course but for the c square yeah and
they take on a5
and then yes you take with the rook and
then the idea was hey now we won the c5
square this is really lousy for white
knight d7 knight c5
and white's
white strategically worse
and then somebody said
i'm
wait a second you know this is actually
not the way chess works and you know
you've got the square on c5 but i can go
a4 bishop a3
uh
uh knight e1
knight d3 and the trade of the b and a
pawn i can fight for the square c5
and it's
actually okay
so then some people started playing
after b4 a5 ba5
uh
yes right here some people started
playing
not rook takes c
a5 but
c5 right and it was like oh
this is a great way to shut white down
on the
queen side you'll play rook takes a5 and
rook a6
and
yeah very very nice and this whole
bayonet attack i mean i'm sure
people have written books on it but the
evolution
of how the light started what the
dynamic thinking was how it changed and
now
with the great chess engines uh what's
going on a lot of people are saying
ignore white
[Laughter]
don't don't don't play a5 don't do
anything go ahead and play knight h5 and
get on with business on the king side so
right that's
but this evolution of ideas i just love
that aspect to chess it's just great
yeah
it's just great okay so then came a4
and f5 i guess a5 and not f6 and a5 look
at that what is spotting for space
advantage right
uh we are getting a word that this is uh
maybe
not really park i'm playing this game
well this is 14 right yeah it's a game
it's a game of iran
all right ethan
and again like
if you go back just a second before this
move e3
uh
you know it's very hard to say like
the move e4 e3
is not
what you would call a natural move it's
not a move that you would intuit
you would think oh you go knight f5 and
knight d4 and bishop f5 you don't think
about playing the move e3
right but right it goes to
show how computers have impacted not
just opening theory but it's impacted
players throughout the whole world that
players are getting stronger and
stronger and stronger thanks to
computers and databases the engines
are are teaching us and training us
i mean
10 years ago i would i would have never
even thought of the movie e3 i would
have thought of bishop f5 i would have
thought of knight c5
maybe right on a crazy no bishop h6 i
couldn't think of sorry wow
okay that's not enough but that's that's
asking too much but i i i'm just i'm
just saying the move e3 is not an
intuitively obvious or natural move
but i'm getting that uh this is uh
indeed not uh parkham's game it's uh his
teammates game and board four and this
is actually what is being played in
parkham's game so maybe i could show you
very quickly
having mentioned his name yeah
you will actually get his actual ah bogo
indium b4 knight d2 yeah
and e4 oh wow okay
e5 90 so this is a very sharp line i
assume that
black is doing all right
right yes it's a very very major line
and h4 i think is actually uh invention
probably i'm wrong
but i would like to give david navarro
credit
for throwing it out there uh h2h4 and
the idea is very obvious white is ready
to play bishop takes h7 like please play
knight c6 so i can go bishop h7 and
knight g5 and
checkmate you yes somehow this is
checkmating right i believe we even have
some puzzles level
i mean starting level at chess.com this
is how you check your opponent exactly
that's exactly right
if you get a success i'm saying this to
our audience if you get a success from
puzzle rush uh be sure to give archer
and jazz credit
oh i didn't meant it really i mean i've
been i've done
the rush runs so yeah g6 very nice
that's very
interesting i like this approach
and quincy two night effects this is
what it's been yeah especially
uh with the inclusion of h6
and the move bishop b1
takes great impact because as soon as i
make the battery with the queen you
can't play g6 h5 is splat
it's just made over there
right yeah how you feel the consequences
having the pawn on h6
absolutely
this is a splat
so this is this is what was played in
actual game uh i believe that we still
can switch to some other game i'm not
really sure to which one
we did talk about
shankland's game and now they have a
different opening yes sir what do you
make of that
for sam shanklin's game right because we
generally had they had the mask
operation and i said it brings warm
feelings to my cart etc
i know suddenly it's open
yeah and i said i didn't like sam's
position so i was really hoping the
transmission was wrong and i got my wish
let's let's switch this game as well
okay pretty sure nicely flat falsehood
in the camera also did not happen did
not happen
by the way uh i remember it was very
nice in the old days uh the the digital
game
uh boards um
were
hypersensitive
so it was this very nice move you could
go bishop on c1 as white
and go bishop to h6 bishop c1 h6
but and this was very important if you
went bishop c1 and lifted the bishop and
then put it on h6 it would go to h6
but a lot of players like to slide
their piece across the board right
so
the game the move could be recorded as
bishop d2
bishop e3
and vision h6 that's not legal is it so
you can imagine a lot of transmission
errors and as we get started in this uh
the first round of the olympiad we just
have to say
that we should
gird ourselves that we will have some
transmission relay errors so uh we'll do
our best of course i think they're
they're gonna manage it definitely they
have a very dedicated huge team in india
they really want to make it as the best
olympian ever and uh i i think there's a
lot of tax already working on these
issues as we speak we can only show you
what we are getting right so sometimes
we get the wrong relay well what can we
say right yes exactly so again a shout
out to our chat thank you so much for
joining us and sharing your day and i do
see uh some of your comments and
we would love to go for example to
magnus carlson's board
of course magnus is not playing on day
one
but uh
we would love to go to a lot of games uh
and we just don't have that ability at
this moment but i do expect
that
as the olympiad continues we'll have
much more
okay
all right i'm just getting a good news
that
uh we've got
better transmissions archer uh yes that
is around the stage uh start with the
board one board one let me just find him
first all right
and again uh india being the host they
have a dedicated table to the indian
open
first
team
right
so what do you have for well the closest
one i have here is uh levon aronian's
game
let's do it let's do it let's jump to
that
and lemon
is doing great for black
is this the game that we wrongly
attributed to sam checklist uh there is
a very good chance yes there's there's a
very good chance because i do see it's
moscow yeah i think you're completely
right
and you praised black for playing really
really good opening and
unknowingly you praised levon's choice
in your head
i wanted to say that i like black's
position a lot after this move queen d6
and and when you said to me that sam
shanklin at the white pieces i was like
oh my god did i have to go go to india
and
and talk to sam
i'm glad i don't have to do that
i mean all right he knows what he's
doing definitely right excellent
excellent i i won't uh book my travel
agent uh but in a nutshell i mean this
this idea not e5 probably yasser you
know it a lot more than i do but i i
have written quite extensive analysis on
this variation with uh what from the
wise perspective and 95 is really tricky
because black allows doubling the e
pawns to stop this d4 push otherwise if
you don't play knight e5 and there's
many good moves there's more like e6
there's g6 maybe even b6 white supply
plays bishop c2 d4 and gets the center
and iranian plays knight e5 and crosses
brushes these ambitions for white
absolutely and also just stop here for
just a moment
so the resulting position is these
doubled pawns on e5 and e7 as you say
but if you look at from white's
perspective for just a moment white we
understand is going to have to make a
break
a pawn break somewhere and you only have
three places to do it
you can play for f4 you can play for d4
and you can play for b4
now playing for b4 is not going to get
you all that great success you can
imagine you play b4 and there's a trait
of c pawns and then what you've got an
open c file that black is able to
contest no you're going to have to play
for d4 and f4 and in that case the pawn
on e5 is perfectly within its rights to
be fighting for the control of the d4
and f4 square so that's double pawns is
actually quite useful and as we'll see
levon
uses the space
to improve his pieces that is to say the
pawn on d6 is on e5 and he improves his
pieces very nicely uh right yeah yeah
indeed
so actually the g6 is quite tricky
because sometimes black plays bishop h6
but before white can touch deeper i
think this is the reason right why i
played d3 to stop it bishop e3 b6
and i guess white is thinking about at
some point to play something like 92
knight f3 and d4 but as we already see
how the game progressed it never
materialized
let's see how it progressed
castles h3
e1
applying pressure also stopping 92 i
guess is this the idea otherwise the
pawn on d3 drops exactly
queen d6 logical i mean very very nice
agreed yeah completely it was at this
point that i thought that black was even
for choice that all of his opening
challenges are behind him and let me be
very clear as a commentator uh with my
audience when we talk about the openings
for just a second because
a lot of people get confused about the
opening and here it is it's very very
simple what are you trying to achieve in
the opening the first and most important
thing is that you want your fair share
of the center you want to control the
center
so you want your fair share secondly you
want effective squares for your pieces
you don't want your pieces to be bottled
up on on
poor squares and the third thing is you
want to save king
that's it that's all you want now you
can get you can go crazy and you can uh
go 40 moves deep and some groomfeld
ending
but from the opening those are the three
things you want and you look at black's
position in that uh position after queen
of three
black has his fair share of the center
his pieces are effectively developed the
knight on f6 the bishop on g7 the bishop
on a6 queen of d6 and
boy when i look at black's king i go
good luck
try to get him
yeah good luck killing the black
yeah i think also the pawn on d3 cannot
be really be taken i guess there should
be some kind of a simple tactics like
rook d1 right okay we've got some issues
yes precisely c4 what is tricky i mean
he is so 23 kind he knows what he's
doing actually this is one of the rare
matchups of the first round when we have
title players there is no grand master
pairings yet because it's the first
round the favorites are meeting against
underdogs when it comes to the ratings
but still i mean david silva is an
international master so it shouldn't be
easy for lebron
no and just on that moment too i was
going to say that spain
got an awkward first-round pairing
because they're up against whales and
wait a minute you know like uh whales
wait a minute they
they play chess in wales so seriously
good games knight h5 also uh kind of an
indication that black is ready to
yes precisely our terms
knight to f4 f5 he starts thinking that
i could make an initiative especially
because
white's not playing d4 and white's not
playing f4 all of his breaks are being
controlled by black's
uh piece uh
deployment this monster on e5 yes and
from black's perspective black starts
thinking okay
e6 f5 and i can have my break and if i
seize more space on the king side that
could lead to uh
well i'm not going to say promising
attack but it's always nice to have the
initiative
by the way also very important to define
certain chess terms because a lot of
people have different
definitions for chess terms
what does the word initiative mean in
chess
it means the ability to make threats
right a player has an initiative because
he has the ability or she has the
ability to make threats so at this
moment if you look at white's position
white
is
not
threatening anybody
i mean if you play g4 you could say ah
i'm threatening your knight but you may
regret playing g4
right then you have a very juicy outpost
on f4 which white is gonna regret
because this opens this guy here in g7
yeah not very good
the monster okay so black is developing
his pieces in such a way that he's
now
ready to assert uh his break f5
right so i guess we're gonna simply fast
forward oh look at that there was an
exchange sacrifice already round one
yeah well i mean uh
in the spirit of tigran petrosian the
great uh world champion who was
formidable
well known for his exchange sacrifices
lavon is feeling the spirit
all right that's his fair famous
countryman of course right
um i love this choice actually because
in in pure mathematical calculations so
what does it mean i know that it's a
scary thought for many club level
players i mean the usually the thought
process is like i'm giving up the
exchange right so in case i'm not going
to check my opponent i'm going to be in
trouble but think about this exchange
for a pawn in the professional circuit
it's being valid evaluated it's
something like uh i'm not sure yesterday
you're gonna agree with me here i would
say half a porn would you agree with
that right okay so first of all we have
to uh again just kind of define our
terms so uh we sacrificed an exchange
lebanon did a rook for five
for
a bishop which is three and a pawn which
is one so you could say that levon
made a
calculation a judgment
that
he will
have a material imbalance
not
in his favor so that materially speaking
black is behind
now
if lavonne had sacrificed in exchange
for a knight in pawn
then again it's four versus five but i
tend to think of a bishop as being worth
three and a half
i totally approve yesterday your
favorite comment commented really
because i i've had these discussions
before and some people disagree but most
of the people do agree that bishop
indeed is three and a half because you
know the position tends to open the
bishop gains strength besides where you
start feel the power of the bishops
exactly you're 100 right it's not it's
not even to discuss but it's absolutely
right
but also
here's the thing
when you're
black and you need you need to win or
you want to win this black you have to
take a little bit of greater risk
and when you look at this position you
say this is
what this exchange sacrifice was was
kind of perfectly ideal
because of now it's putting a lot of
pressure on white white's sitting there
saying you know his teammates are coming
up to them and you know patting them on
the back and saying you know
you've got a material edge you know it's
really really great make yourself look
good
okay but now
let's
dissect the position for just a second
and we go
i have an exchange yay
what does it mean
it means i have a trump
rooks are great
when they have open files
shut up
now
in this position the rooks are not
strutting their stuff they're not
looking
great because
the open file in the center well there
is no open file in the center in fact
the d-file and the e-file are both
blocked by these pawns so for white
white starts thinking okay
i need to
bring my rooks to life right how do i
open up the position in my favor should
be d4 right should be d4 and you start
to think that that's once again where
i'm aiming
and levon is sitting there thinking yes
keep thinking like that that bishop on
g7 is sleeping
but that bishop on g7 is going to become
awake
as the position opens i think that this
was a great
choice i i probably would say i prefer
black in a practical game but i wouldn't
be surprised if the chess engines called
it
even even right i would say also it's
going to depend if white is going to
manage to bring the queens off the board
because naturally black has those two
bishops and if white is going to push d4
i mean look at the white king it is it
is weak right we have some dark square
weaknesses and d4 is a very responsible
move because for example you have to
account for black at some point maybe
even pushing e4
and just exploiting the weaknesses of
the white king exactly we have to be
very careful that
white doesn't have a counterpart to the
bishop on b7 so you know
this awareness
that that diagonal
could cause you know
you know your your feelings to get hurt
so be careful with that diagonal what
other games uh
let's jump around the stage and and
treat our audience
as to uh the various games we've got
yeah maybe we we have to find another
game and i'm thinking can i find
uh fabi is not playing here today no no
he
he's taking
we we talked about the jet lag
yeah the giants yeah the jet lag impact
so we got wesley so he's playing with
the white collar again sergio miguel and
i do believe yasser we had this position
correct at the start because that was
one of the very first positions
transmitting the correct moves assuming
this is the correct
uh
relay should be
yeah
it was a nimzo right the
rubinstein nimzo with e3 and recently um
i want to say that wesley has really
adopted or taken to
white's setup
with the bishop on d3 and knight on e2
and even the bishop on d2
which is kind of interesting because it
really is an echo
of uh previous world champion michael
bondinic
bond vinegar used to like those setups
with uh the bishops on d3 and f3 and he
would go rook a2 and g4 and
swing the queen's rook across
and uh wesley uh
kind of uh picked up the spirit of bobby
yeah yeah so nimzo indeed is a source of
many sharp games f3
ideas like a g4 rocket as you already
mentioned maybe e4 this bishop on c1 it
doesn't appear to be doing much because
at the moment it's just staring at the
pawns on e3 and a3 but
strong players they're thinking ahead
and obviously wesley is a very strong
player and he knows the position is
going to open and this bishop here on c1
could become easily one of the strongest
pieces on the board
absolutely and sometimes it flashes
out to a3 and as you mentioned archers
when you do get the move e3 e4 in
then it's very natural for it to develop
to a g5 and tickle
the knight on
f6 and finally the knight on e2 is
terrible let's be very very clear that
knight on e2
is not earning its keep
the knight on e2
needs a better
role
and when you start to think well where's
a good square
yeah you highlighted it right away
g3 and f5 the pawn on e6 is moved to the
d5 square the
the square f5 is weak
and
when your opponent has a dark square
bishop and you don't
don't play the move g6
[Laughter]
yeah you're gonna
do it
trust me on this one
at some point indeed this could be a
problem this is actually how the game
progressed after queen a6 i find it an
interesting that wesley didn't mind the
trade queens so he treats yeah queen
trade it's fine fine i i get to fight
for some some central squares
a4
well this is really odd right you play
g4 a4 and according to the bar
what is
simplynbc structure c3d
or f3 e3 this structure is lending
itself nicely to a king site attack and
we're told that when we're attacking
we should be keeping pieces on the board
and that usually involves the queen
so the
with the elan the grace
that
wesley just agrees to trade queens it
might confuse us right you know aren't
we supposed to be attacking especially
with the move g4 no i mean wesley's uh
done a lot of work on these
endings and right he definitely
recognizes his structure
yeah
he
loves the space and
the move g2 g4 was trying to control uh
the um
the squares and he's gonna i think i
think he really really cares about his
bathtub structure because
unofficially this is known as bathtub
okay this pawn formation so you see here
after seed eggs okay obviously edex is
impossible the knight is hanging after
seed eggs seed eggs he keeps the
precious pawn structure but jokes aside
i believe there is a common
understanding that you want to have as
few porn islands as possible because you
look at the white position you have one
island this is the second island for
black he has
one more so that's one two and three
which might become targets
precisely and by the way the worst chess
book ever written
was pon power and chess by hans kamak
and this book that tries to
give names
for every pawn structure there is
so and they got it
but i actually like bathtub compared to
some of the things that he invented i
mean you know the he did he he mentioned
every terrible pawn structure and gave
it a name and it was just sort of like
kill me uh the guy was so off the mark
but i hadn't heard bathtub before
right right
so it's always fun uh
doing commentaries with uh with with
our this has been our first right so i i
i pick up some new terms
so
i just like
to be the only one when my wife asked me
what did you what did you do today i'm
going to say well archers and i
took a bath together
did you know what
right honestly we took a bath
okay we have a bathtub after night now
wesley is looking at knight c2 and he's
saying
i got to avoid the fort
also rook c a truck c2 could be an idea
so i'm not really sure i feel that i
mean i see the bar i see the validation
by the way we probably have to mention
yeah so that we are not using engines
here right just of
pure brain power
which is very sad for our audience who
are seeing bgs engine's evaluation i see
the bar the bar says 1.4 for white and
actually i'm quite impressed it's so big
it's so big advantage obviously black is
about to suffer because of the sweetness
on d5 should it be something like 94 g5
yes uh that that is one way but the
other thing is
um
and i got this from victor korchnoy the
pawn on the e3 is weak right the pawn on
e3 is weak because it's a backward pawn
on a half open file
but victor
drilled into my head the following
concept
a weakness is only
a weakness if it can be attacked and the
crazy part is when you see the move rook
b1 please please play the move knight c2
and go ahead archers play the move
knight c2 so you are attacking the
weakness the pawn on e3 but now after
king f2
you might have regrets
that you're going after upon weakness
that is not a weakness at all in fact
white's pieces are easily protecting the
pawn on e3 if worse comes to worse the
move rook on d1
to d3
can be used and then
the rook on d3 could go to c3
and shame the attacking knight
conversely just what you were saying
white is ready to play moves like h4
knight f4 and g5 and attack the pawn on
d5 which is really weak and not so easy
to defend so this pawn on e3 has this
appearance of weakness until you drill
down and you start to say well it's not
really weak
and white's plate
i always liked that
when i had a position where all my moves
were natural and easy
right nf2 h4 knight f4
these are natural moves easy easy to
play and black has to start thinking
should i be playing rook c8 rook c7 rook
c8
doubling the rooks on the c file should
i be playing doubling the rooks on the e
file
should i be playing as you're pointing
out a5 should it be going a5 rook b8 b5
uh a lot of different ideas for black
but
not every one of them is natural and
easy to play
so i'm not surprised that the bar
the engine bar gives it a big evaluation
in white's favor but
it does feel
like
black's position's not that bad
that it can become
bad in the next three moves
and it can be like really bad like
bad to the point where you know there's
no
saving the position
i think we also need to jump on uh
please check some other games otherwise
let's do it of course we would love to
check all the united
states games i would big favorites you
would i would we also need to check what
else is happening here and i think would
be a shame to miss what is happening in
the match
and i i think we could jump in india
playing against um zimbabwe
and uh
they desperately are looking
to score a big result in own one exactly
this also has a kind of uh
bayonet like features with the move b4
but also the same-ish
light features with the move f2 f3 so
right
kind of a mix of vienna seems to be a
hot topic right now right right
second game already been played a5 we
talked about this not your c5
no
no you suggested c5
uh makoto says no it's not going to
happen
right
and knight b3 this is really odd right
this weakness on c5 white says it's not
a big deal because you can always play
bishop a3 bishop b4
i think black plays for example b6 you
still need to reckon with ideas like
a5 because in a nutshell what kings
indian is all about i mean white if we
go back from the starting position so
white is supposed to attack on the queen
side expand gain space
get some of those weaknesses and black
wants to checkmate the white king so he
goes totally crazy f5 f4 g5 g4 and
somehow there's the main okay
that's the dream
that's the dream anyway yeah
and from white's point of view just as
you said it's easier for white stream to
come true white is not looking for
checkmate on the queen site no
white is looking simply to open up lines
on the queen side and that usually
involves
4 c 5 and knight on c3 to b5 so while
black's goal
is to check mate white white's goals are
much much
smaller just opening up the smaller i
love that
yeah and for the moment too by the way
in this whole uh wonderful explanation
the knight on e7 again you know this is
a mule
that's not earning its keep
the knight i guess black is going to
play
here something like this f4 g5 knight g6
g uh g4 and try to make a good use of
this knight or how do you usually play
maybe 98 even
it's too slow uh g5 uh
pardon me f4 g5 g4 it's too slow you're
not gonna get there
probably you should be thinking about
bishop h6
bishop that's a great check
and bishop to d4 in order to slow white
down from knight b5 c5 and captures on
d6
also i think you were just about to
suggest knight g8 to f6 what happened in
the game
um i don't think there's any more moves
because bishop is the last move so black
is thinking about his choices i wonder
if he still has time to play something
like c5 i mean maybe but then again
you're probably gonna agree with me
because this is where black doesn't want
to play he doesn't want to play at a
queen so he doesn't want to create more
targets for white and c5
it's a very responsible move exactly
you will have to analyze opposite
c5 d takes e6 knight takes c6 knight b5
very very carefully because the pawn on
d6 could be uh
how do you say seized
paid attention yeah right
yeah so the pawn on d6 is weak and i
think if black could play like c5 and
for one move exclude the ampersand rule
that you're gonna take on c6 he would
just play it in a heartbeat because this
would essentially kill the counter play
for white at the queen side exactly and
again you know the rook on
the rook would drop back to the a6
square and
cover the d6 pawn so that you could play
responsibly knight on e7 the g8 and
queen h4
and you could give your checkmate very
deliberately and carefully yes
responsible very responsible checkmate
very nicely done
so uh once again a big shout out to our
audience uh welcome to chess.com
coverage of the
olympiad olympiads are very very special
and again having participated in 12 and
been a spectator and another 12
i've always enjoyed them
so much and i think that uh
uh
for a lot of countries um
it's special just to make the olympic
team you know it's just like yeah i want
to play on the olympiad and i was
talking to jeffrey zhang a young player
from the united states a very
top up and coming grand master and it's
sort of like
i want to go to the olympics and i want
to play for the united states team i
want to make the olympics and the first
time i broke through and made my olympic
team it was very very special and so
countries all over the world
uh you're seeing a lot of very
bright faces
they're very
uh they're very uh
grateful i want to say uh to be able to
make the team
so i think uh we're ready to make a
break uh yep let's let's make a short
break i think we definitely want to
continue
following at least one game per top
leading uh players also probably want to
go back to the women's event because
this is also happening in parallel
there's so many games we simply have to
choose what to show you i mean just
don't go anywhere make cup of tea or
coffee and see you in a couple of
minutes i'll do it
[Music]
okay we're ready for a small press
conference it is something that has
never happened anywhere in the world
before to have correctional facilities
all around the world playing at once in
a chess tournament army is very proud to
participate in this tremendous event it
will be an honor for us to be part of
any of your future undertakings
last year
we organized the first international
intercontinental online championship for
for for prisoners it was
31 country participating
40 teams
five female teams i know without name in
the country
that some maximum security facilities
where prisoners
could not be
more than one in a room before i met her
i would never like that people do that
i think yeah it's chess competitions but
all over the world online throughout the
jails playing against each other that's
a whole different
thing like he opened that up
there was a incredible
level of anxiousness that was neat that
reminded you of how athletes would be
before the big game before the kickoff
[Music]
[Applause]
india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad the most prestigious team
chess event on the planet
in chennai the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
a top three seed in the open and the top
seed in the women's section the host
country has legitimate reasons to
believe it can sweep gold
the united states are the top seed in
the open section fabiano caruana and
team usa have come to chennai saddled
with heavy expectations of gold or bust
norway has never meddled at the olympian
led by the best player on the planet
magnus carlson leads a squad looking to
change all that
while medals count
some accomplishments won't be measured
in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste dosto
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that
let the games begin
namaste
we are back from the 44th uh world chess
olympiad in chennai india yasser servant
i'm arthur nations we're your hosts
today round one has already been ongoing
for how much is it one or two hours a
lot of action
and i i think this is a good moment you
also have to jump into the ladies
section and check what's been going on
there well after that wonderful profile
featuring on a
museuk let's see if we can bring up
ana's games
yeah let's do that and uh anna mozaco is
obviously one of the strongest female
players in the world representing team
ukraine
uh here she is playing against jessie
february a fellow just calm streamer
who is representing south africa in the
event and uh the bar says well sorry
jesse things are not going your way and
anna is about to score
according to the bar at least a victory
at least visually it doesn't seem so bad
for black but
maybe it's just like support
yeah at this moment uh
the knight on c4 makes such a
nice wonderful little crush yeah doesn't
it though
uh a real visual i must say um
not only enough the uh ah
i see the uh camera tilting up it wasn't
so easy to get a good uh idea of the
game i was looking from the
camera point of view
as opposed to the two-dimensional look
and again a big shout out to our
audience thank you so much for joining
us
um we are
going through our day one and of course
in the first day
finding our rhythm and our form and
going uh what's your take archers of
this position
i mean white i i sort of borrowed my
evaluation from the bar i mean i cannot
uh depend i cannot really uh
think that i
don't see it i see why it has an extra
pawn the knock on b6 knight on b7 is
incoming i'm just curious yes how it
happens really so maybe we can do it
like very quickly
jumping through the moves
and enjoying the show power show by anna
mozarchuk this is how you all play your
opponents right after the opening
rubenstein
french
there's early trades on e4 and
the kiva rubenstein was really famous
for
trying to neutralize white's opening
advantage here so we'll find c5
actually black appears to be doing fine
okay knight b6 i i think yeah you
probably you also saw it it smells like
oh what is that i mean
b6 i mean what's it doing there yeah the
problem is i think that uh black was
facing knight e5 and queen eight for
check oh right so that was uh
yeah that the desirable knight f6 would
allow this type of action and
victor kochner uh
would describe it as unpleasant
sensations
this should be pretty bad for black
right bishop c exactly
oh my goodness this pen is killing
unpleasant sensations and that was where
the move knight b6 came from
right i mean knight b6 i think normally
you don't want to make because in the
perspective if white is gonna play
something like b3 uh create a spawn
chain at the queen side the night on b6
exactly exactly the knight will be
offsides all right okay i think i jumped
a bit too far i have to go back again
and uh we left it
here yeah rook c1 rook c8
take it okay b4
and c5 so yes sir i mean why does baka
the idea to play knight e5 and queen a4
she sure is and again we've already
determined that that could be very
upsetting uh series for
black
how did she respond
95 here queen a4 check i guess
i guess here instead of uh queen c7
queen b5 was not very good you normally
want to play this but then after a4 this
is what we call help mate or
help help trap i mean you trap the queen
it's not to go really right yeah
oops and now
that's an oopsie
yes
check and knight e3 and what just claims
a better position the king is weak g6 is
gonna be played there's gonna be bishop
h6 check and
right and black decided to give up a
bone
i'm not happy with that decision of
black to give up that uh
uh you already you know it's sort of
like
your king you you've lost the right to
castle so there's something a little bit
trashy about your position
but you know a trashy position where you
can
somehow bob and weave and cover up so
let's imagine black had played the move
a7 a6 for just a second and then white
plays castles
and you play
uh g5 just
oh that's very aggressive very
aggressive
you stop bishop h6
uh and you suffer
and then you suffer and then you suffer
and that's okay and you suffer okay but
when you suffer
material down
it's a different type of suffering right
actually i took the words out of my
mouth
it's a different god of suffering right
but when you have a bad position
and your material down then you feel
like your opponent has material
advantage and the compensation
and it's kind of hard to yeah to to to
fight back from that so i'm not sure i
like black's decision to just
uh toss away the asa a7 pawn that's a
useful poem yeah definitely also for
anna this was a good choice to take the
pawn go back because now she she has the
pawn a healthy position he has the pawn
and the compensation like you said it
yes queen b3 the king is still not
feeling safe right right
just normal normal moves yeah yeah not
f4 maybe it was not the best decision
because g3 some love for the king
knight c4 and now jesse is thinking i
also look at the clock i mean anna is
not spending too much time here because
to remind you the time control of the
tournament they get 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves then they get extra 30
minutes after move 40 plus additional 30
seconds per every made move
yeah every uh move you get that 30
second increment and you know also i'm
looking this position and i'm saying oh
wow lights really i don't want to
you know keep the praise on white's play
or something like that but what i do see
is knight v6
knight d7 check
followed by queen g8 and catastroph uh
is going on here let's let's just show
some example let's say black was totally
aggro at the king side yeah okay
something like rook i say c6 which is
not good but i just want to prove my big
point here
yeah and this is how it could end that's
the catastrophe yes
so
again white's
with upon and
uh the initiative
and that's really
enough for anna she's such a a powerful
player
in the women's game and you know she's
been doing it
i want to say her and her sister
actually maria been doing it for 15
years uh
they
i mean she's got this game in the hand
already even though it's still early it
looks
overwhelming
what do you think yesterday we move on
we check
connor's game
because she is the top board today for
team india against antonova
he has a very tough task trying to stop
the top seed india
which has gathered such an impressive
lineup as you already saw it before
absolutely one other thing i actually
got a chance to meet uh
conoru uh for the first time at the
karen's cup
in saint louis
and i got a chance to talk to her and
ask her you know like you know what's it
like being a top
uh women's player and playing in india
and all the rest
and
i must say i was really stunned by a lot
of the answers that she gave me i would
not have expected
her answers in any way shape or form
first of all i find her style to be one
of maturity uh showing a great
understanding and strategic play and in
fact she's such a good strategic player
she very often times does not play
tactically because she wins so easily
her game she has as great
i want to say mature styles i said hey
you know like
who taught you to play like that he said
my dad
oh and i went what
she goes my dad
and i go oh wow is your dad like a
grandmaster i am or something no no no
he's just my dad
oh okay okay so and who's your trainer
did you get a chance to work with vishy
anand or
hare krishna or you know any of these
really really great grand masters for
the nba that you have no
i never worked with a coach ever
okay
i was getting shut down on everything
else that's big it's quite an
interesting topic because india i mean
obviously everybody knows uh those uh
great uh players and the younger
generation like dukesh and prague and
ericazi but they have also wonderful
coaches right and uh probably one of the
best uh coach in the world is ramesh rb
right yes and uh he has been preparing
uh many many young talents so it's just
just impressive and this is what we
don't see every day we see obviously
those big names who are
scoring those big results but we don't
see people who are making it happen
exactly well
what i wanted to say in nippy's case was
this idea that
she really was on her own the all india
chess federation
you know they've got so many challenges
in india and they've got so many talents
and there's so many
ways that they want to improve
themselves it's not been easy for the
women's game in india and uh
you know
tanya and uh
for the most part you know have fought
and made their way i hate to say it
individually you know not a great
uh i would say
reservoir of support
for the top ladies
including uh
homie and i i was just really surprised
because sometimes i think we in the west
take it for granted
that countries like china or india will
have some government agency you know
writing a nice check and
you know you get all of the training and
support
that you could possibly want and it's
just simply not true uh they that it's
tough it's yeah it's still being
difficult yeah
especially for ladies so it's absolutely
especially for ladies yes right
uh so let's maybe check very quickly um
how did they get to this position i
think it was some kind of italian game
it was right yeah everybody plays the
joko piano these days
uh yeah
i think i think we have to thank
vladimir kramnik for that right uh he
should be feeling a bit
responsible he was the one who came up
with this berlin
lopez
right yeah i mean you know
he has a very very bad karma and it will
he will be punished
[Laughter]
so i mean
those of you who don't know what we're
talking about vladimir kramnik in his
year 2000 world championship match
against gary kasparov he unleashed the
beast which is the berlin system against
ray lopez and it proved to be a tough
nut to crack for the
now formidable champion gear gas proof
and ever since it's become so popular
that people started even to avoid it and
italian game is one of the reasons
and
himself said that uh
one of the things he learned
you know as it as a beginning player
was the italians like all of the italian
open
the scholastics player all learned to
play the italian and then
somehow in the year 2000 onwards a lot
of the top players discovered that well
far from being played out the italian
system offered a lot of
subtlety and nuance that was unexpected
right right indeed and this this d5 it's
a bit more aggressive continuation very
aggressive very aggressive right so
white is uh laying his eyes on the pawn
on uh e5 which is actually not so easy
to defend because think about moves like
rook e8 which might seem the natural
response oops there's only d4 and you
cannot take it because the knight on e5
is now bye bye it's gone yeah oh so
we're gonna do that right
so mg4 is necessary
and then also if you end up playing a
system with f7 f6 well you have to be
very careful with f6 as well because
look at what you're doing to the
diagonal uh oops
yeah you're making
moves like b4 and queen b3 very very
attractive so indeed yeah that looks
very very scary i think i would be very
scared to play that i think from the
talent player's perspective f6 sometimes
is played when black plays king h8 and
then he does play f6 and d4 is not so
scary anymore right and i've seen a lot
of black players in this position
playing the move knight b6
and offering the pawn in a way and
bishop g4 yeah and this is what has
happened the bishop g4 included
yep so yeah again i think there's a
couple of continuations here i seem to
recall this idea of bishop b3 bishop c2
sacrificed the board on d3
right yeah knight e4
was
played
right
all right
f5 i guess is incoming
[Laughter]
yeah being telegraphed if you will yeah
right so knight g3 i mean it's all about
the f5 push so white is getting ready
for that i guess immediately f5 is a bit
risky
yeah h3 this bishop is something you
don't
want to give up this powerful light
square bishop because then the pawn on
f5 is weak and g6 you have bishop h6
issues this is just not how you want to
play it no not at all and not at all so
rookie three knight h4 oh look at that
this is h4
yeah
okay that's a little bit of a head
scratcher
so it's like a let's play a draw i'm
like oh no no
we need a score
no no
queen went back to d8
yeah what
okay
and h3 this is what's on the board
well somehow in that whole series of
back and forth moves i think white came
out with the upper hand
as she got in her first you know hit to
the bishop and
trying to drive the bishop to a lesser
square
actually i like wise position here you
know yesterday i look at this
for example bishop d7 there could be
even something like d4 and suddenly all
of white's pieces look really good
targeting the black ink here that's
precisely the type of move uh i would be
very attracted to as well
um also
uh
to my way of thinking the knight on g3
kind of did its job its job was to
to break the pin of the bishop on g4
like uh
you you didn't want to play h3 and allow
the bishop to go back to h5 and maybe to
g6 where it would pressure the pawn on
d3 but now that the bishop is going to
go to the lesser square d7 i'm thinking
that i want to play d4 like you
suggested archers i think that's a very
good move but i also want to play knight
e4 takes d6 and d4 as well so if i could
get in those two
ideas of knight e4 and take that bishop
and play d4 i think white is definitely
for shorts
yeah i think we also probably have to go
back to the open section because uh i
think told aronian is in in some trouble
wow
sacrifice that was the exchange
sacrifice that uh
we were both uh
praising
let's see all right so apparently
there's something wrong it's not so
simple for him
is this trouble
no is it really trouble it's just maybe
the bar slider doesn't like it
i think somebody's been paying too much
attention to the bar but when we left it
i'm gonna say wait a minute
okay we left it about these parts right
here we kind of
i was warm to
black's position what did lavon do
that uh
we can be critical we can criticize
he obviously was concerned about the
move d4 right uh for example i mean what
do you do if you play something like f5
you go for the king set attack you need
to properly validate what happens after
d4 because i think
the strategy the
the structure of this position is that
white is really interested into training
queens so aronia decided to put the
queen on d6 i guess with the idea to
meet d4 with e4 i guess something like
this d4 c dex c dx e4 this must have
been
uh
yeah his agenda
uh something queen a fork happened
on queen b8 b4 look at that really
interesting
play by david silva here were for white
he's thinking when we left i said that
one of the things that white is eager to
do is open up a file for the rook and we
were looking at i said that white
actually had three breaks if you
remember about four
d4 and b4 and if white doesn't get in
any of these breaks he's go he's the one
who's going to be on the back foot he
won't have any active play so it's nice
to see the move b4 but i'm i'm troubled
by the decision to play queen d6 if we
could go back to that position just
before
i mean to my mind and again i think
every player should do this
every player should be thinking
strategically at all times even when
they're tactics uh because tactics are
like the watchdogs of strategy right and
what i mean by
thinking strategically is you ask
yourself you ask your pieces how are you
feeling how you doing is everybody happy
you asked your bishop on d7 and you're
happy you're happy so to my way of
thinking the knight on h5 is the one
piece that's not happy
if i could transfer the the knight
magically to the square f5
yeah then the knight would be yeah i'm
feeling good so why didn't levon play
knight g3
maybe it's something to do with the same
idea before perhaps we slightly focus
still more too much on the move d4 maybe
it's the b4 idea again white is
insisting on the queen trade and for
example something like this
no it's not fairly clear if black is
enjoying his pawn for the exchange
because the position opens and the spawn
chain of the king side
you know perhaps it doesn't really play
a big role
if we just continue one or two more
moves so we go knight f5 for example all
right
we've achieved our
yay our redeployment of the night knight
to f5 and rip to d8 so there is a a pesh
key on the um
half open d file that we want to tend to
write
by the way it
in case
uh the move
rook c1 ever occurs right i was thinking
that the bishop might end up on the a4
square i don't know
it seems a little bit peculiar
yeah the bar also thinks so it's a very
very peculiar very yeah but i what i was
going on in my mind
was i was thinking that in a real ideal
world if i could ever keep my bishop on
a4 and play rook takes d3
the combination of my rook and my bishop
would dominate the knight on a3
so that was maybe a little bit of a
strategic overreach but that was the
plan
that i was counting on
well
that wasn't what levon did what lavon
did was very different from from where i
was heading with the knight
right so he placed the queen on b8 i
guess as far away from a potential trade
as possible because one of the unique uh
capabilities of the queen of b8 is just
white simply cannot trade the queen
because it just runs away right and
after yeah before queen before rookie
eight i have a feeling that it's white
who is dictating the pace here because i
mean look at this
lawn chain it's just not moving forward
right
yeah a little bit uh
for for sure
those pawns aren't good and it really
feels like
black on the other hand really needs to
improve his beast play
uh
in a number of ways knight went back to
f6
this is not what you play out of good
life right yes right
well the idea is to just say you don't
play c5 knight d5 would be uh
marvelous from black's point of view so
knight f6 has a kind of a defensive
reaction it's trying to stop
maybe he didn't have the time for f5
there must be something he didn't like
because i imagine you want to play f5
not f6 and then play e4 to open up this
guy here on b7 so that he can create
some targets and i guess lebron just
evaluated okay f5 is just too slow so i
can only guess what was the reason it
must be c5 so if i try to get here
knight c4
i agree i think that was indeed the
whole
concept that uh levon did not want to
allow and that's
yeah now this knight f6 actually stops
c5 because you have now 95
exactly and you know you get this bishop
here and you have a complete control you
have what you call it um total
domination of bishops because what we
have no bishops you have to
exactly uh by the way that what what for
me was very interesting is robert james
fisher bobby
bobby fisher called uh
winning the two bishops uh a minor
exchange a minor exchange yes so you
have the idea that i sacrifice a rook
for
for a
minor piece
and you win the minor exchange so after
knight b5 what happened next yeah after
95 97 so this knight is re-routed summer
time
yeah a4 a5 wing b1 king g8 okay this
already actually spells trouble for
ronian because i mean when you sacrifice
an exchange like that on only exchange
for a pawn and then you have to play at
some point later moves like knight f6
not e7 king g8 this was not the original
plan
he has to change something here yeah
exactly
and uh okay we'll uh jump if you don't
mind uh archers let's jump into a norway
for a second and again yes we are very
very aware that magnus carlsen is taking
a rest
for his first game and we'll jump to the
game between faisal and johann sebastian
wow is this an upset in the making
just a second i see the bars
completely up
like and uh
white is whoa and it drops then it drops
again it did not but it said that this
was the moment that white could really
hit
home
likely with some very aggressive move of
bishop b5 and queen c3
those two moves
bishop v5 queen c3
and
even
yeah
this is uh
this is really getting scary
now how do you remove this knight
right
yeah i'm really feeling like the
tactics the tactics are very favorable
so how did this actually happen we we
have to check really this is how you
play against strong grommesters
so take notes
by the way back where he said
yeah that that uh
position with the
the the finishing position almost like a
fisher random game there's a white queen
on e1 and a white king on b1
somebody did a fisher random
yeah
it's quite odd right indeed right why is
the queen not e1 i mean king on b1 i
kinda get but all right let's how did we
get here
i mean okay okay we just observe and
and uh
enjoy it so that was a pawn sacrifice
knight c3
i guess f5 is risky right you just
sacrifice ball like this yeah they're
very happy to sacrifice pawns in this
this way
right
yeah knight f6 queen e2 and i remember
this was going on in a
predrag nicholas game i want to say
predrag great great player from bosnia
and now living in well many years
already in holland uh liked the french
and people were doing crazy things
against his french and he would play
this position as black and white was
getting in these moves g4 as well
once the knight
goes to f6 you know so g4 is still
incoming you're saying
it's incoming yeah okay
so if you for example played a move like
bishop e7 white's idea is not
to play knight takes e4 and to allow
trades and black has a very easy game in
those cases
but the move g4 and bishop g2 and h4
this is your showing archer
and uh
i like interesting yeah yeah exactly i
have some which
begs the question why i'm not playing it
myself with what
you never you never get a chance to
attack these guys like trust me our
tears
they won't let you do this okay get away
with it so what happened after knight c6
yeah so knight c6 was played it makes
perfect sense to attack the queen
long cast 94 queen e1 this is called the
queen got an iran by the way okay that
explains that
oh look at that i mean he's not taking
the pawn so clearly clearly he's playing
according to what you recommended i mean
except of g4 opening the position yeah
brilliant sacrifice i like it okay
i guess the idea what was that this is
risky you look at this development here
for white this knight on d4 is a major
target and the king
is going to be
visited very soon
yeah for example if you go castles
knight f3
knight takes f3 g takes f3 i'm upon down
as white but i'm feeling like i'm the
one with the initiative i'm going to
play rook g1 the bishop on b2 keep in
mind of course bishop takes d3 check the
old discovered czech sacrifice to win
the queen for rook and russia
this is a black on the back foot
amazing yeah that looks very good
so what happened instead yeah so if i
was played here christensen decided to
sacrifice the pawn because this is what
the experience of players do they feel
that uh oh i mean my opponent has
prepared something nasty against me i
have to get out of here right i have to
secure the style on d4 take the pawn
back just let me live
yeah this is what happened dx97 but
white says no i'm gonna continue
now that move i really like that is uh
as they say going for the gold i mean
that's a that's a very nice move you
want to undermine the knight on d4 and
you want to play knight f3 queen g3
and
as the brits would say
get the bits out
yeah the so far this is really
impressive stuff i mean look at this
knight e5 not f3
and king b1 i mean
is this a move which would jump to your
attention yes sir it would it would uh
seriously uh it would uh because i'm a
pawn grubber i'm an old old old guy and
i like protecting my pieces and my pawns
and the mood knight takes f4
i is a kind of a move i always find
attractive because that gives me the g3
square but then i see a move like bishop
g5 and i find myself compelled to play
queen g3 and king b1 in those cases so
the move king b1 i would find attractive
but in this particular position i
probably would not play it because i'm
feeling
that with the king on c1
i want
i want to stoke
the fire
so if you put the king back on on c1 for
just a moment
the moves that i would find attractive
are immediately bishop c4 immediately
bishop b5 oh that looks too good yeah
and if you're not
the you know
i i like that people think of me as a
positional player
so
i try to frighten them
and i would say the move i find most
attractive is g3
oh wow g3 open the g file for example
open the g file and then people start to
think of me as a tactician
and then you finish them off in the rook
engine right yeah exactly
and always i'm looking for the extra
pawn in the rook
so i'd like to
to sacrifice your pieces the pieces of
the norway the norwegian team
yeah i i definitely i i can relate to
that yesterday because i also love to
sacrifice everybody else's pieces but
exactly exactly it feels really good
really good really good so we're gonna
have to keep like a big result here
could be making
okay but now
i look at this position after the move
bishop f6 and i go gosh
if e
4 e5 does not work
uh for black it's like
all black is going to get this
incredible sense of relief if he could
trade the dark squared bishops it would
be like oh
my my my worst
nightmare is that i was going to get
checkmated on the g7 square
so
if bishop f6
if
black gets away with bishop f6 without
losing material
uh and if e4 e5 doesn't work for white
then it's sort of like i lost a lot of
the
power the the the oomph i had at the
position but but yes sir i'm getting the
clock right i do see 11 minutes for
black here so clearly he was not
comfortable with the position no that's
the only move 15
yeah
so he's in a lot of trouble here so he
needs to make something like 25 moves
still an e5 by the way he's on the board
p5 and the bar says up
absolutely well again we were just
talking about the bishop versus the
knight and the three and a half for the
bishop the three for the knight if you
will i see that bishop on e5 i'm playing
knight takes e5 in a nanosecond
not a second all right
i'd like to say like okay what comes
next
should be right
well
no
oh bar doesn't like it though this is a
very brilliant point yeah oh that is a
brilliant point indeed um
i was afraid that if i go bishop takes
e5 something scary like yeah queen g5 or
queen e7 no maybe queenie or maybe f6
no f6 is a mate
that's
beautiful the show
i show my puzzle solving skills
immediately
by the way i love puzzle rush i like
puzzle survival is my favorite of them
um but okay that's a nice checkmate but
i would play knight takes e5 knight
uh knight takes e5 and maybe here
moves like queen g3
i find that move really attractive the
ride i'm starting to think that you know
i'm crashing through with a knight h5
business on g7 and it's not easy
to
that there's this nasty nasty pin on the
d file go ahead and put queen g3 just on
the board for just a second yeah okay
let's do that queen g3 and i'm saying
that okay
if you were black
what's the first move that comes into
your mind
every grand master in the world
hates
with a exclamation hates to be in a pit
we just hate it we just we we know it's
not good it's not a healthy situation so
we're always trying to get out of any
pins whether we play h6 and g5 or in
this case we move our queen but if we
move our queen to e7 or f6 we're
inviting knight d5 that's another pin
another issue here in c7 yes exactly
exactly annoying and we we start to
think that we're just getting killed uh
the pieces are coming out way too fast
so if we can't immediately solve a pin
uh
we understand that white's pressure is
really overwhelming by the way i'm
looking at the webcam and it's nice to
see
again i think the the playing hall
that looks
like one of the nicest playing halls
i've ever seen and i remember in moscow
in 1994
i was playing on plastic chairs
that look exactly what you would put on
your back porch
right but these are not plastic chairs
right these are looking like really nice
uh i won't say executive shares but they
look
like they've got good uh comfort
going i think we could we could see an
upset here like many other games uh sure
what do you think yes sir we continue to
browse through more games i see there's
another interesting game which is being
played right now in jordan one forest
game
uh with the black color against monsoor
serene and
here
what what is this
well um just life has an extra piece
right
just counting
[Laughter]
i mean there's the saying right that uh
sort of a joke to my in my grandmother's
opinion right black is an expertise
yes yes that was very famous from
a soviet
journalist how did he write a a an
article
it was an adjournment and it was like
say
uh rook and three versus rook and two at
german
and uh the soviet uh journalist was
writing in in
the opinion of grand master michael
botvinnick
white is upon up
so in the opinion of archers uh black is
a piece ahead
mike is a piece again he's doing great
indeed he is uh
right but okay now that we're here
how
uh how do you get the piece up exactly
this is what really makes me wonder
always how do you get these great
positions a piece up
so
and why doesn't that happen more often
in my games
look at that i mean cpap very aggressive
some sort of uh
what do you call it
benko structure c5 d5
b5
i'm not sure what this is really maybe
benco benoni
all right with this early e3 by the way
berusia nakobian a very strong player in
the united states loves these bishop g5
e3 systems against
both the grunfeld and
the king's indian and he's
he's he's had a remarkably good career
so
yeah i'm used to seeing it when
i played blitz against var
[Music]
all right
c5 bishop b2 g5 so black lames i'm going
to get your dark square bishop the
position is going to open and this is
exactly what happened dx knight g3 data
x and i guess black already is pretty
happy there's some prospects to utilize
this bishop for good
except there's some awfully weak light
squares knight takes g5 is suddenly on
tap that is a brilliant point i was
about to bring up
i see that uh you had already uh
how do you say highlighted
yeah there's some issues here obviously
so yeah that's why black
defends upon g5 with a queen
okay always when you make such a move as
e7 e6
you you should hear the cries
being made by the bishop on c8
the bishop on c8 says
coach
what are you doing there right
give me some luft yeah yeah what's my uh
what's my role in the game okay e6 what
happened next e6 not e2 so i guess black
is i mean white is going for some
aggressive f4 ah
okay so
then this doesn't make sense what white
did i apologize go back for a moment
okay so
when you make the move knight to d2
exactly here exactly now
it's obvious you want to castle long
you want the castle long so that your
knight can then uh
the rook on d1 can hit the queen
yeah otherwise you don't play knight d2
in this position with the knight on f3
you would play rook h5
why would you play rook h5 you play rook
h5 because you want to double the rooks
right but
no
you really want to take the pawn
you want to double the rooks and you
really want to play knight takes g5 so
if you could ever get black to play the
move f
7 f6
well that would be uh hopeless i mean
you're just waking too many you're
inviting queen g6 and rook h6 and god
knows all kinds of horrible things will
will it's going to be a horrible fate
so you play rook h5 with the idea of
encouraging g4 so if you could go back
for just a second archer play g4 now you
play knight d2 and everything that white
is doing starts to make sense you're
ready to castle long you're ready to
double rooks you're ready to play rook
c5 and bishop jesus oh you're still born
on c5
yeah
yeah so you're ready for this but
you start with the move rook h5 with the
idea of castling long when why play
knight e4 without castling
then
something's wrong then he's not
i i don't follow the the logic
so clearly for white no it's going to be
quite difficult to bring the other rook
in the attack
f2 maybe yeah this is how the game
actually progressed okay this is
something else
that's a long long route for the night
right once again 92 not e4 g3 knight g3
not h5 black just plays one move
there it goes uh
the quarry escapes
right
win b1 bishop g7 a3 queen e4
on bishop d
three he run into
f5 so clearly he anticipated knight
before with queen h7 check what he
missed is inter metro move
beauty
he was forced to sacrifice the the beast
he has missed this nice uh
move f5 changes completely
the tactics
right
so this was played so he got no choice
for at least so he actually blundered us
queen h7 now long castle but now it's
too late i guess exactly
well
all right so jordan looks really in a
great shape to win the game i guess what
you're supposed to do in these positions
when you feel that your material
advantage should be sufficient to win
the game
this is what we call the simplification
you simplify exactly trade trade it's
been working for 1600 years
still works
queens rooks trade right
and
as wonderful as it is to praise the
organizers and it is very wonderful i
saw in that profile that that was
created uh
india
uh
invented the game of chess
uh not true
india invented the game of chaturanga
which was the precursor of the game of
chess in fact chess as we know
has been in a state of evolution
and the
it wasn't like india invented the modern
game of chess and has been played
for 1600 years but the game of
chaturanga changed
uh on the song
like what we've mentioned that was the
queens the bishops uh were all very
different from the original game of
chattaroo so it would have been better
for the profile to say the indians
invented chaturanga
you know the seeds of the modern game of
chess were developed in india
right
all right
um yeah so i think let's continue
browsing through more games and there is
a very exciting game by the eternal fire
on the board alexa sheriff my former
countryman who now plays for spain and
he just managed to conjure something
something amazing and this really brings
me some memories where have i seen this
before
right
feels like a peace sacrifice in some
super sharp sicilian but i'm used to
seeing a pawn on a6
so now i'm confused how did we get here
yeah let's let's just check that okay
how did we get here so it's uh some sort
of affiliate or failure g4 look at that
yeah this is how you sacrifice a ball
right here aha
very nice so white says i don't care
about the pawn i'm gonna activate my
rook rochi one
open the ge file obviously long castle
is in the cards not f6 bishop c4
obviously this is theory so that you're
not confused knight g5 idea start appear
and black has some issues you know
defend this pawn on g7 easier said than
done
yes exactly so uh
for philadelphia defense players i think
the move g4 should be met by h7 h6 and
not
knight takes g4 i think knight takes g4
is just asking for trouble
as black well he got it
yeah i think you're right h6 maybe it's
a more
uh more modest contribution however then
again you look at this position after
moves like rook g1 and the question is
how exactly do you want to meet white's
continuation of bishop e3 committee to
long castle because if you're gonna try
to hide your monarch at a king side
hello hello there
it's not gonna work very well but
it i mean they have developed uh systems
for black against rook g1 which involve
early captures on d4
followed by knight to c5
and they try to slow wipe down by saying
protect your pawn on e4
you know these types of things um i
meant with the inclusion of h6 and rook
g1 all right sorry
yeah i meant h6 rook g1 you take you
take and you go knight c5 and now it's a
little awkward for you to play bishop to
g2
well you know you just put your rook on
g1
and so on and so on but
let's see what happened in the game
because knight takes g4
maybe allows alexei an opportunity to
strut his stuff
yeah he knows absolutely he's best how
to play these sharp positions because
alexa is widely regarded as as one of
the most created and creative and
sharpest players in the circuit
yep
uh queen d3 b5
actually you know i was already yasser
looking here at some potential sacrifice
zombie e5 maybe
you know you're paul murphy
yeah yeah you know what yeah exactly i
was looking at this and i was thinking
is this morpheus
exactly this is modern 21st century game
of alexa sheriff okay yeah like the the
opera game as it is known in right try
the opera game right yes
okay the space six narito the bar says
it's completely equal nothing to see
here
yeah c5
that's awesome for c4 that's what's also
very offensive to me about the
chess computers today or
ever since is you get some position like
this like this is crazy position right i
mean
material and balance uh the king's in
the center my gosh white's king is under
pressure and it goes zero zero zero zero
like you go no this is the sharpest
position under the sun i don't know
what's going on and then the computer
gives you this evaluation that you think
i think actually the engines sometimes
take the easy way out they just find
some gun for perpetual check or
something repetition they're just like
hey listen people you just figure out
yourselves right
i'm tired
i'm tired i don't understand this that's
why it's equal
i mean you show this to a chess player
it's obviously wow this is so sharp
right because i'm not gonna
g7 and c5 c4 was a big idea apparently
okay the bar says no black is slightly
better go figure
right i i again i feel
i feel like i'm offended
[Laughter]
crazy
son bishop b7 okay
and these guys
bishops i guess there were some issues
with knight c7 check at some point right
but every
tempo is so critical i would i would
think that this was the right decision
is to trade down and go
queen b4
you know if i would play against sheriff
here i would love to tread all the
pieces so yes
lacking them to attack me
exactly and and keeping them on the
board this is dangerous thing because he
knows perfectly how to make good good
good work of them ambition bison keeps
those pieces on the board
bishop detail queen c5 bishop b4 queen
ca this is
what's happening right now you know i
don't know yes or what what is this but
it's asking for some some direct shots
in the center
great i agree i'm sure how do you do
that
right and then
i'm starting i think with the move
bishop a5 because what i'm really
thinking
i'm one of those very strange players
where
when i totally
misjudge a position and i put all my
pieces on really really profoundly
stupid squares
i try to justify my decision
so the queen on f1
is incredibly stupid like why is my
queen on f1 why isn't it on f5 or b3
yeah so
oh i understand why the queen is on f1
the queen is on f1 because i want to
play f4 yes
i see it now the vision is clear
if i play f4 and i open up the f-file
i'm a genius but wait a minute i don't
want to suffer the consequences of
bishop takes d5 and bishop takes b4 so
i'll play bishop a5 try to gain a tempo
so i can play f4 so i think if i'm in
alexis shoes
i've got f4 on my brain as well as
knight c7 checks and uh
i'm trying to
but now that i
i think black should also be trying to
trade the pieces too right on t5 square
and uh this is double edge what is the
current position
uh this is the current position by the
way dear viewers uh we are from time to
time checking what you're saying um
there in the chat i appreciate all the
good words all your insights this is the
live position and i i think it has
definitely a big potential to go
completely nuts and i'm thinking
i could even consider something like f4
of course barr hates it but the idea was
something like bishop b4 rook g7 and
just throw everything just throw
everything online maybe not like this
but you get a point oh definitely i i
more than understand exactly your
motivation
to get such things on the board because
first of all it's always a lot of fun to
sacrifice other people's
very good points
and one of my favorite quotes i have a
lot of favorite quotes but one of my
favorite pro quotes was one from your
countrymen michael tall
and tall was
asked to
explain you know he was no longer world
champion he won the world championship
in 1960
against michael vodbinic and lost the
return match and he said
the interviewer asked tall something
along the lines of like are you upset or
sad that you're no longer world champion
he said no no no no no on the contrary
my losing the world championship was
fantastic
what yes now the soviet
children could all go back to learning
how to protect
and to defend their pawns and pieces
instead of learning how to sacrifice
them
and i had this vision of like 200
million children in the world
oh i'm so happy i don't have to
sacrifice anymore
but actually you know yasser i think was
it in that interview or a different
interview he also said he is not very
upset because now he is the youngest
world x world champion ever ever yes at
least at the time and he also said that
uh
being the ex world champion is one of
the best titles you can have
because you can never lose it
it's safe it stays it stays it's not
hard to keep it yeah
another great great quote again one of
my absolute favorites was from this
swanathon denand
vichy vichy's doing an interview for an
indian journalist
and the journalist says uh mr anand what
is it like to be the world chess
champion
and vichy says oh
it's a very good question
every day
i feel like a sportsman
some days i feel like a
scientist
some days i feel like an artist
and some days i feel like an idiot
and i guess that's it
that's what it's like to be world
champion every day you feel like a
sportsman
actually you know yasser i had the
chance to talk with vichy a couple of
weeks ago because i was doing commentary
for the bilges festival and vichy was
one of the honorable guests in the
studio and also he answered some of the
burning questions about for example
magnus's
decision probable decision it was at the
time not to defend his world
championship cycle and he said he would
said i i can i can relate to that i can
understand it because it's very tough
it's tough to keep this job right so i
mean
it's tough being a world champion
yeah uh i relate to that too except i
come from a different uh
period of time i i started playing chess
in 1972 i was uh
the bobby fischer boom generation if you
will
and by the time i was in my 20s and 30s
being a chess professional was not
difficult in the world of chess it was
impossible as a westerner
and most of my
colleagues who were professionals were
actually writers they they were books or
they
like in the case of robert byrne he was
a candidate for the world champion but
it was actually his new york times
column that paid the bills so it was
very very
tough to be a chess professional in the
west
and
the idea
of playing a two million euro match
would have been just like a godsend like
i agree
[Laughter]
i want to be in the finals playing a 2
million
euro
chess match
and every chess professional in the west
would have immediately agreed
uh and today it's a different day that
magnus carlson can say hey look you know
it's it's too much stress
i will decline a two million euro match
because you know it's just hard
right but what
it's it's a different age right
obviously with a chest booming online
all those super tournaments thanks to
the kovid obviously right just managed
to bloom online
we have a lot of chess on twitch
everybody's following it we have a lot
of streamers it's a different age
there's a lot of super tournaments i
mean imagine yes or something like i
don't know five years ago if someone
would tell you like yasser you know in
in five years we're gonna have super
tournaments online so you'd probably say
are you crazy
yeah no i mean
for sure there's no question about it
archers and uh
big shout out to the audience who's
watching right now as we speak that we
are living there's no question about it
in a golden period and the internet and
the streaming has made it all possible i
mean the fact that that that so many
people are watching as we're
talking and
the
sponsors i can see that they're that
they're going to be putting more and
more resources into chess
and
today right now is it's never been so
good
as now to be a professional just it it
it's the best moments and
i personally am very very very grateful
that such moments exist and in the
united states the sinkhole cup the u.s
championships there's a reason why
america is
hosting
or having the number one team in the
world because
our team
is really comprised of professional
players in a lot of the years
before bobby fischer
we didn't have a professional team that
uh people
were driving taxis being accountants uh
sami reshefsky the great giant of
american chess was a certified public
accountant that was how he paid the
bills in his family
and today that people can devote
themselves to chess is fantastic by the
way i see that
uh alexi did in fact play the move
bishop a5
he's looking for some clarity i i don't
think he really cares about this rook on
d8 he was more thinking about his check
on c7 that's all he cares about exactly
and black says no you're not going to
get it it makes me get the check yeah
i want to keep the d file open so i'm
thinking bishop takes d5
will be alexi's response
i can't imagine a move like bishop e7 i
can only imagine bishop takes d5 what
you had because bishop e7 just simply
hangs the pawn on g7 if nothing else
if there isn't
some other way and bishop takes d8
yeah
eventually i'm going to warm up to that
idea especially if the d file stays open
so knight d5 bishop d5
bishop d5 rook d5 what you put on the
board
and now
black
you know
you know knight v6 queen b5 check is
gonna hurt my feelings but
a lot
i mean of the queen 5 check there's just
no way to properly defend that this this
guy has to walk already and rookie 5 is
just killing bean right there exactly
exactly so
i'm seeing
alexi uh and i'm looking at the webcam
it's hard to tell from his face but i
think in his heart of hearts
he's saying i got this game in the back
sure it looks like that and um yeah it's
difficult to tell of course from the
black's perspective where exactly he
went wrong
i think my gut instinct says that this
bishop b7 keeping more pieces on the
board allowing alexei to conduct uh even
more dangerous attack was probably not
the best choice but the bar says i mean
it was still a good choice
uh something here went wrong uh i guess
they didn't like the bar
our favorite uh bar a little
bishop takes d5 uh
maybe
maybe bishop d5 yeah maybe bishop d5
yeah but what's the next small right
exactly
i mean you got it
you got to play one day bishop c5
you you got to develop
but it doesn't uh it doesn't feel right
to give up the g7 pawn
although the bar says there's uh
something wrong with rook x and g7 i
don't know oh that's a good news then
if something's wrong with rook takes g7
what could it be maybe take take and
some sort of
just king of faith maybe on black lanes
there's no attack
wow
and the rook escapes by the way
ah that's interesting by the way uh
i think that that has been
underestimated by uh
people at large players at large
is when they say what has been the
greatest impact that computers have had
on the game
in chess engines i meant to say not
computer because
databases have had a huge impact but
chess engines
is chess engines have taught us the art
of defense
in my day you know gary kasparov was
just you know like beating people like
bowling pins with just one idea just
crushing them with just a single idea
and now today you see that the people
are defending
incredible resourceful
right i mean you couldn't really compare
how it was wow
yeah it was a lot of one-sided games now
everybody knows how to defend right
so and they get in trouble yeah they get
themselves out of the most difficult
horrendous masses
and they find
especially for me hikaru nakamura is
something extraordinary he really really
is and what a lot of people don't
appreciate about hikaru is he
just
defends so incredibly well i was really
surprised he lost his last round being
with dingler in
the fashion he did because he's such a
resourceful defender he finds ways
of saving his skin time and time and
time again
and i think that that's just true across
the board with these great players of
today they're wonderful attackers magnus
carlson can attack with the best of them
but his defensive skills are
extraordinary
everybody's universal play is just great
and i think
i think chess engines have taught us
that positions that we thought were just
bad
and undefensible were actually not true
they're not bad at all and that's been
an extraordinary
uh insight for me
personally
well probably we have to still continue
to switch the games i'm not sure i think
alexis is going to do very very well
from this position that looks to me
like he's got this game
that's that's how it looks yeah he's got
this he has a strong attack he's about
to take the rook on d8
not really sure which game next i should
check i could check very briefly
check some of the games of india because
i've got to pay our respects to our
hosts
sure we have uh any of their games
absolutely i think we could go back to
village satosh guerati game against
makoto rodwell this game we had a look
at pretty much right after the opening
it was kings indian by your name
right
that was the strange uh line with the a4
that we saw
right
yeah this a5 we had a lengthy discussion
how the modern theory is changing here
that a white wants to expand at a queen
side black says no i have an attack at
the king side apparently there's no
attack at least based on what we can see
in the position there you go see if it
was played
okay because we that was
and we were thinking beyond poisson was
going to be white's response as well
and it was yeah so dx
takes on bishop d3
so what with it is saying here your
weakness on d6 is not going anywhere
first i want to secure what's happening
in the center against 94 ideas
now your page six yasa that you
mentioned which is one of the common
ideas
activated dark sweat bishop bishop e3
king h1 knight b5
white lays eyes on a pawn on d6 black
defense
well there you go this is not checkers
right you're not obliged take on c5
exactly in checkers
i'm looking at this king on this long uh
diagonal and uh
i have to say that uh
i would love to make the illegal move
rook on d1 captures t4
oh and that player
exactly so i'm thinking i just probably
play bishop c2 protect the a pawn in
that situation and prep
prepare rook takes d4
maybe actually that's the reason why
black decided not to do it he didn't
take it he took with the pawn he takes
on the e4 exactly bishop sito is on the
board hinting at your ideas of exchange
sacrifice oh yes before queen e8
what do you make of this
i'd say black is doing his best to hang
on and i got a feeling that uh
white is really
enjoying uh this position a lot
definitely enjoying yeah and that uh
i'm really really fearful that um bishop
b2 and rook takes d4 that black king
sitting on h8 and not having a bishop on
g7
um
it's gonna cost them the game so bishop
b2 can we just get that position on the
board for just a moment yeah there
should be two queen a4 i think it's
still not yet played but i'm pretty sure
that will it's eyes are glued on the
beetle square he's looking at something
on d4 i think he's dreaming about these
ideas let's say can i do this by the way
rook d4 exchange sacrifice right now can
i do this
i would like to keep the queens with
queen d3 but
uh this
this looks favorable for white i was a
little bit more afraid that
black wouldn't take the exchange but
maybe harass
the bishop on
like queen takes queen takes
yeah
rook takes rook takes d4 or yeah
bishop b4 yeah
well rook d4 yeah and i was i was more
worried that black might just uh play a
move like rook a2
oh
and and threaten to give back the bishop
[Laughter]
who's gonna be the one to sacrifice
right
looks overwhelming for white in fact uh
i take it but maybe but maybe after
queen a4 you simply don't have to trade
queen to play something like queen e3
and that is a good with the comfort yes
that that that i really uh
appreciate uh for white as well
so i think uh that it will be very happy
do we have other
games uh we have we have on board to i
think it's originally
uh the young star from india you know
actually i'm not really sure what was
their reason how they chose the lineups
because the way i understand it
it's team number one it's the uh the
main team and team number two for india
it's the youngsters team right guys he's
a youngster right so technically he
should be in the second team where is
ducash and prague
and um everybody else and yet he is on
the top team
yeah uh
one of the
i don't know how it works in latvia for
example
but
it seems to me that across the world
many countries use different
means of creating their olympic teams so
some
teams
have a committee
a committee decides who's one and two
three and five and six
other committee other teams use ratings
and they just say you know you're
qualified by rating what good for you
and then other teams say well
we're going to pick archer archer is
going to be our team captain and our
team captain will decide to line up and
do everything so how the indians chose
their team is probably a mystery for
even the indians
themselves right i mean they kept such
an amazing lineup they easily can
create two teams and this is what they
did team number one team number two they
are probably going to be fighting for
the medals and also team number three
all of the players are over 2600 all
right just incredible how many strong
players they have i know
they're they're deep
and vishy is not even playing right i
wish he's not even playing
okay yeah i remember yugoslavia uh
nobody saw it uh i think it was 1990
no wait 19
wow 1990 i believe had been
then afterwards came um the philippines
but yeah when novi sad they had team a b
and c
and at a certain moment the united
states played team c
of yugoslavia and it had like ivan
sokolov
on team c and i was like dude the lungs
on the a team
like what's he doing on the tvc
it was it was pretty funny you know like
how they chose their squat
but
nice uh
so we've been trying to monitor our chat
we were that we're in day one we've got
a lot of things going on with all of the
cameras and the transmission of the
games and i'm sure as we go on uh with
our broadcast we'll even be better about
bringing
you our comments on the games but i
think our tours were ready for a break
yeah that will be a great moment uh just
to wrap up what's happening in eddie
guys's game in my grandmaster's opinion
kiki has two extra pawns which should be
pretty good it's pretty good for keep
the score of victory so cheer up all
indian fans right we'll be back in a
moment right
absolutely see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
and we're back live the live coverage
for the 44th world chess olympiad in
chennai india yasser servant and our
connections we are your calls today and
by the way i want to mention before we
jump in with the action from mikhail
siren's game from team india if you have
some very interesting questions in the
chat don't hesitate to ask us and we're
going to try to
deliver you
hopefully interesting answers
well that's the whole trip right the
interesting question
yeah only interesting questions allowed
indeed hello everyone and thank you for
uh joining us our coverage at
chess.comchess.com is going to be
covering all the rounds of the olympiad
and they've got so much
material i want to say so many assets on
the ground in india and they made a very
nice profile
of our host country let's check it all
right
the host nation india also happens to be
the top seed in this year's women's
olympiad
surprisingly india has never meddled in
this event but the time to do so is now
with her top women's squad team a
2011 world championship finalist humpy
canero leads this team
she's the highest rated player in the
entire women's event
because canero will be favored in every
matchup team india's success likely
depends on a great result for her on
board one
but india's chances by no means end with
humpy
india has one of the strongest second
boards in the event as well harika
dronovalli a three-time third-place
finisher in the women's world
championship journal volley is likely to
be a key contributor to success in
chennai
vaishali rameshbabu is the third board
for india and is by far the youngest
member of india's top women's team
for playing board three vaishali earned
some bragging rights over her brother
pragnanda who plays a fourth board in
the open event
on this team the fourth board belongs to
commentator extraordinaire tanya sachdev
in fact sachdev has represented her
country in every olympiad since 2008.
in 2012 she even won the individual
bronze medal for her board
the experienced bhakti kulkarni
completes the tournament's highest rated
roster
a medal may be unprecedented but with a
squad this strong gold is clearly the
goal for india's women's team a
well talk about that really impressive
video here made by our producers about
india's lineup here in chennai the 44th
world chess olympiad
and i think yasa what do you think we
could jump into the action of
nikalasarin and talk a little bit about
what does it mean for india to cause
this olympia
well first of all let's start with the
obvious uh
uh india came in
as a last minute replacement it was
really
these olympiads
really require enormous enormous amounts
of planning i mean the teams of
volunteers oftentimes number in the
hundreds of persons and when you think
about the translators and the visas and
the hotels uh the complications just
multiply
so
when
we went to baku in 2016 i think baku
had actually won the event four years
prior
and they did all the planning and
everything like that four years
so originally
the idea was moscow and then for obvious
reasons the v-day had to pull the event
out of moscow and search for replacement
india stepped up and from everything i
can see
uh including
the nice cameras
of the playing hall uh they've succeeded
beyond
wild streams i mean it's just such a
difficult event to organize and now that
they have organized the event and it's
actually
taking place now it's about the play and
the gold medals and you know meddling
and just representing and
we can jump into the game because uh
well uh india
has everything to prove
absolutely so nicole and nicholas aaron
is
playing for the
second team of india india d number two
of the youngsters
so once again uh to remind you
um
india has three teams nonetheless so the
second team has the mirage cache was by
the way yesterday in the opening
ceremony with prague
lighting up the torch of olympiad new
tradition started by india nobody else
did it before at least in chess
olympiads so i hope yasser that this
tradition is going to stay it was really
really wonderful and then also in the
second t we have nikal sarin uh ademon
and ronak sadwani so i think adiban is
going to be like the experienced guy to
keep together the youngsters right
and we can expect a lot from them
no question about it and for me i never
really i i'm a big sports buff i i love
i love uh sports and i love the olympics
the olympic games
the international olympic committee and
i never really
paid never no mind if you will
to the torch and the relay of the torch
yeah i had an awareness yeah yeah yeah
but then came a barcelona spain
and muhammad ali
who was suffering from parkinson's
disease at the time so he had shakes he
was the one who lit the games and i
thought
wow
wow that was just so cool uh muhammad
ali and from that moment on i began to
really appreciate what the torch relay
is all about and this uh
spirit this flame
of the olympics and uh now
if
from that moment forward i want to say
it took on a special meaning and now
that it's been introduced into chess i
can't feel anything but
pride
yeah i love i love yesterday's opening
ceremony
yeah and by the way nihal just played
this move rook e1 which i think is a
tremendous move uh because you're going
to play rook to e8
and you heard me talk about you know
grandmasters hate to be in a pin but
when you go rook e8 that bishop on f8
you're physically incapable of getting
out of this pin now if you move your
king you drop your bishop but in the
meantime as you as you're suggesting our
archers uh
white will double on the eighth rank the
bishop on b8 stops queen c1
shaq and queen f4 per pet for petrol
check so i think neon is winning
with this move
right
um
that looks really really good yeah
really good
for for me
there is a by the way yes or a question
for you in the chat oh in the chat
uh what does it say
what's your favorite moment from your
time playing in the olympia
oh gosh
oh dear
uh
too many too many uh uh the
the the question's not answerable uh
let's start with the obvious um
the bermuda parties
the
bermuda uh has made it nick fox big big
shout out to nick fox who has been the
sponsor of these parties during the free
day or the night before the free day
bermuda has hosted
uh
a party the bermuda party where all the
teams come and just have a wonderful
wonderful evening of friendship from
camaraderie and so on uh
i will go so far as to say 20 marriages
have occurred
because of the bermuda party and it
might be more i mean trust me when i say
the bermuda party is just a marvelous
get-together
and i have to i have to add really those
of you who don't know what is bermuda
party it's unofficial or official
unofficial event a gathering a big party
of chess players which happens all the
time in the olympians exactly exactly
this is the bermuda party right right
and it's not just the weddings either
there's been
fisticuffs
people
people have taken exception
at certain moments and i i i asked
alexander ivanov uh
why he punched and knocked down
uh
grandmaster edward guffelda during the
bermuda party he said it's a tradition
the traditions have to be kept i i
appreciate that so bermuda parties are
great if you're asking me as a
competitor
um beating gary kasparov uh on board one
for the us team leading the u.s team to
a victory over the soviet union two and
a half one and a half
that was
definitely a highlight
another one was maybe when i won a gold
medal individual gold medal uh
in moscow in 1994
and i refused to go to the closing
ceremony because my team was not invited
with me
i was invited individually to go to the
kremlin and have a palace meeting and
that it did that and i said only if my
team and they said
we are only inviting olympic medal
winners so i refuse to go
and gra and when they called my name and
i wasn't there
uh
grandmaster vasily smislov
got up
and accepted the medal
on my behalf
and i was honored that uh smithslav uh
did that for me
that uh a man of his enormous stature
replaced me
[Laughter]
so
uh i have some great great uh
memories and it's impossible to say
what's my favorite by the way uh
um
now that there's a big ups
right yeah let's just take a look at the
game of lavonna rollie and uh
bonnaroni is suffering against david
silva he's done exchange he just lost
the pawn so i mean we probably don't
have the time to check what happened
before all i see is with my bare eyes
the exchange is missing it's not there
and also department e5 is gone so
iranian is in trouble here this could be
a minor blow i guess for team united
states if indeed this happens i'm pretty
sure they're going to win the match
either way but they need to score as
many points as possible and this could
be a very early wake-up call things are
not going to be easy for you despite the
fact that you're the big favorites here
no question about it uh
wow uh the rooks we've talked about the
exchange and the fact that white's rooks
were on e1 and d1
where the rooks had no open files now we
see very
clearly the open b file for white moves
like queen c7 queen uh d6
i'm thinking levone's in real trouble
and the problem is the slight square
bishop look at this light square bishop
and again you think strategically
what on earth is your light squared
bishop doing and if you cannot yeah
exactly
if you're not playing
e5 and bishop f5 or you know that bishop
needs a life because
as soon as white moves his his knight
away i don't care knight d6 knight
c7 i don't care where the knight moves
the rooks are coming off the board and
things are getting scary uh 96 by the
way would threaten queen but there's
still one trick that lavone might have
hidden
under his sleeve it's he might always
offer a draw and you know
know this is sometimes that the players
kindly accept because imagine yourself
you're playing with white you have this
great position against levon and ronin
himself right and now he offers you a
draw are you thinking okay probably i'm
doing really great but the question is
am i going to win him really do you ask
me to win it and then he offers a draw
right maybe this is just already a great
result i'm not saying this is going to
happen but i've seen it happen so many
times
for sure star power and sometimes that's
your grandmaster has to reach into his
bag of tricks and come up with something
as absurd as that that if lavonne really
thinks oh my god i've really gone too
far i've i've blundered blender
blundered
uh
i'm gonna pull the brakes and offer a
draw
uh
hopefully my opponent will take it uh
but i'm what i'm looking at right now is
not good i think that white is
hugely favored and if lavonna was on the
white side of this it would never cross
his mind in the million years to offer
and draw his life
i remember that happened to me once in
um
one of these world cups
the 128 player knockout i had won my
first game
against vasily von chuck
and i made a move as black in the second
game and i got up
to go to the bathroom
and
i was thinking about the game and it
suddenly occurred to me that the defense
i thought was his only defense i had a
flaw
and it actually was not a good defense
but that was the only defense i saw for
him
and now i suddenly realized
oh i'm just completely winning
like i'm just completely winning i come
back to the game and vasily makes the
move i had expected and offers me a draw
and then instantly instantly without
even thinking and hesitating i i
accepted the draw
all right and i was very proud of myself
to accept the draw and he said well you
know you're winning they go yeah
because that wasn't what i was there for
what i was there for was just to qualify
to the next match
exactly that's all i i i mean i could
have won the game by putting in another
hours of work and who knows what will
happen in my next match but i just
needed to
qualify to the next match and one and a
half half did it
all right
this this game is definitely something
we want to follow it could be a major
actually major upset i i wouldn't be
surprised again i i mean seriously i
wouldn't be surprised if they would
agree to a draw because i've seen these
things happen before so i agree let's
see what's happening here and i think
what we could do is mention some of the
results that some of the games already
have been finished and actually team
united states have scored already one
victory because it's dominguez lanier
perez he scored a victory with black
against his opponent here you see this
is the final position are clearly
dominating position also for team norway
team norway already leads two and a half
points because john lloyd v hummer
managed to beat his opponent in pretty
much flawless positional game we didn't
really have time to check what was
happening there
ari and tari also beat his opponent
in a spectacular attack so it seems he
was a significant uh elo favorite and
one of the upsets that we actually
thought it might happen christensen
managed to escape at a draw and this is
exactly what i was telling to you uh
yasser right i think it was yeah this
moment they agreed to draw you see the
bar is
completely winning completely with it
like not even not even close
at the right moment you offer a job and
you just ask the opponent are you gonna
i'll play me here if he just change it
like probably no so i'm down a pawn so
accept the draw
[Laughter]
yeah
it's great to have that
oh boy what a how do i gravitas that you
could offer a draw from a completely
losing position and your opponent
starts it and it's really nice when you
can do this because archer so you have
to set the situation so imagine i'm
losing i have a very bad position and i
offer my opponent a draw so my opponent
does the very cl correct and proper
thing he says i will consider it right
nice nice nice so now that you've
offered the draw it's been acknowledged
that the draw has been offered you get
up and you walk away you get yourself
some water whatever then you suddenly
notice that your opponent is still
thinking it's 10 minutes later and he
hasn't accepted the draw eventually when
they get to the 20-minute mark it's a
hundred percent that they're going to
take
because now they convince themselves
that the position is not as winning
normally speaking
when the opponent's going to decline the
draw offer they do it right away like
you know in just 30 seconds a minute two
minutes but whenever they go past
i'm going to call it the 15-minute mark
then you could be absolutely confident
yeah because i think also now we're
talking from our own experiences
sometimes when you offer a draw you're
just like begging for the opponent to
offer the draw because you feel
uncomfortable in that position something
is not right uh you just pray that the
opponent is gonna agree to a draw and
yeah indeed after some like 15 20
minutes you get the feeling okay okay i
mean it's going to be drawn it's going
to be dropped everything's good
everything's good it's all good it's all
good
by the way we do appreciate your
questions so any questions from the chat
uh again uh our tours is qualified back
with they have to be interesting
and we will uh take
[Laughter]
we have some what do we have here which
player are you most excited to see i'm
not sure who is supposed to answer this
maybe archers you go for it which player
are you most excited to see me
personally yeah i don't know i mean you
know i tell you honestly i'm not sure if
i can be biased
could i can i really cheer for one team
please
i i would i would love to see india
number two play very good
because i'm a big fan of the youngest
generation i also had a pleasure uh to
meet in person uh a week ago uh embile
uh dumaraj agukash he's such a humble
guy
and at his age only 16 years old he's
already 2700.
yeah so i would love i would love to see
them perform well so maybe
yeah could perform really good here i
like uh i'll be done uh
he's like a remarkable for me i i find
myself drawn to these tactical beasts
and that's always nice to see uh yeah
the young players uh especially
um for me
i'm sorry that i have to
say it like this but in truth i'm a
fanboy where uh magnus is concerned uh
i can't help it but feel like where
whenever he's in a competition
uh he's magnetic in the sense that gary
kasparov was
magnetic i
remember gary playing in his first
olympia me too by the way in 1980 in
malta in 1982 in the cern and in the in
the lutzern olympiad his game against
victor korchnoy uh ussr versus
switzerland anatoly karpov declined to
play against victor korchnoy so gary
kasparov moved up a chair
and uh
gary played one of the greatest olympic
games i've ever seen we were just all
just totally mesmerized
talk about fire on board everything was
on free and for like 10 moves everything
was on free and it was just like
i don't want to call it the game of the
century or anything like that but uh
gary's gary
uh he just drew
is almost like a black hole just sucked
you in you just drew your attention and
for me magnus is that
person he just
his games are just fantastic and i i i
so all due respects
world chess champion all right all right
that'll be his choice
yeah the world champion is uh not um uh
yet playing here today maybe two switch
right
yeah please
so there was a draw agreed in this one
yeah there was a draw obviously so i
thought we could very quickly have a
look at what is happening in some other
games and
i see team poland is one of the highest
rated teams obviously in the went and it
would be a shame not to check how the
leader rather slavery is doing here
because i suppose duda has taken a a bye
today right ooh uh
well i must say that white's putting up
a good struggle here uh
from syria
so that's an extra point for black
and by all means black should be winning
but it's not trivial
not real at all because what happens
after
and i think that white's chances of
drawing that position is much greater
than black's chances of winning so
some difficulties here for poland and
no results so far in this key matchup
right
so this is board number one board number
two i believe is
for team poland
uh casper pierrong
uh here we go
um here he's playing with the white
collar
[Music]
oh g7 just the last move rook t5
was on tap but what is going on here so
hold on it's an exchange
but wait a minute there's a three and a
pound sorry
connected
right yeah
but no it's the three connected past
pawns that have my attention
i mean push them baby
you know i would start with something
like rope takes t5 and c6 and make sure
that i just got c6 p5 b6 c7
and it's a girl
right
all right nice all right um what do you
what do you think yes or do we go back
to our onions game uh very quickly have
a glimpse because again absolutely dear
viewers uh we can also do it like this
for example you see something really
interesting
um
maybe we can have a look at uh a glimpse
at that game as well right so you have
to also understand
i think it just
it was where yeah there was a social
media question
free answer
i can't see it very well
or yasser what are some of the top
ranking african
countries this olympiad
well um
in truth uh
there was a time that there was one
african country that really stood out
and that was tunisia they had slim
bouasies
and he was a really great player for
tunis and then the egyptians
really have improved uh extraordinary
and today i would say egypt is the
team to look out for but
south africa
traditionally has been uh the strongest
uh team from africa and now i just see
across the board that
more and more african countries are
putting teams of master players together
they're not just you know experts and
lower amateurs but uh
yeah
that that they've improved
enormously just just simply enormously
and again you've got the game of levon
aronian and boy is he on the back foot i
mean his position looks
awful with a capital a
right this just looks terrible for
for for lavon and if yeah for lavond he
simply he has to accept the queen trade
yeah
he scrambles his way out of this we're
going to call him houdini
houdini lavon
i see it correctly that's uh ronian's
game there
could be it's a draw
not really totally sure
it looks like i saw the kings in the
middle the power structure looked
exactly the same again i'm not totally
sure that's the board we are seeing
there
yeah from the light cam it looks like
some games have been completed but then
it should
on the scorecard it should transmit
right
all right so we get the word it probably
is a rhonian's game and it is a draw i
told you yes sir i told you this is
going to happen so you just you just
keep this joker play play out at the
right moment he knows he knows he's a
big favorite he offers at the right
moment indeed right oh was agreed
david silva makes a big result today
making a draw wondering but of course
the final position is
very close to winning of course i
remember i played in my very first
olympiad in 1980 in malta and it was a
big match uh usa versus the soviet union
and i was playing war ii can you imagine
that gary kasparov was the second
reserve
for the soviet team
second
research and we were losing the match
very badly
uh two and a half half i was wide
against michael tall
he had a superior position
and he offered me a draw
and our strategy for the team before the
match was any draw offers we have to go
and tell our team captain about the draw
offers because that maybe he would
parlay
the draw offer into something else right
so i went to pal benko and i said uh and
tall had the better position by the way
he had the better so he was offering me
a draw from strength if you will
and i said pal
and he looked up and he was
he was afraid we were going to lose the
match three and a half half or something
like that
i said misha just offered me a draw
and he said really
and i go yeah what do you want me to do
he said well
do whatever you want because
all the other games are resolved
so i went back
and misha
half stood up with his hand out
and i said i like to play
he was better and his eyes bulged out
like what
and behind me
my team captain uh paul benko who was
originally born in hungary started
cursing in hungarian
right
he threw the bulletins in the air
it was enormously funny it was just one
of those positions i liked even though i
knew i was worse i liked the position i
i won i won the game by the way we we we
lost the match two and a half but that
was the right choice yeah if you're
going to decline the draw
do it
ideally immediately
right but don't
don't don't suffer it for 20 minutes and
curse yourself one way or another it's
not good what what position do you have
on the board by the way um right i
opened the only remaining game
i believe from united states because
united states at the moment have won the
match already two and a half against
half a point so
uh upset upsetting result for lebron
still he should be quite happy with the
draw and it's the remaining game that
the united states is having samuel
shanklin plays against uh junior
dominguez the position is just great
yeah isolate the pawn on the e5 you want
to i guess somehow get the king on the
e4 and snatch the pawn on d5 and when
the pawn engine
the abcs of chess as you just described
it archers and uh i find the move rook
b8 rather
interesting
because you just as you described it you
would want to play the move rook e8
check
in order that if you could
push the king to f6 then you would play
king d4 versus happily and again as you
said abc's of chess
so the fact that white
didn't play the move rookie eight but
played the move rookie
undoubtedly after rookie ate shaq black
would have played rook e6 uh i don't
know what else black is supposed to do
but i just find it interesting that
yeah and then you play king d5 i just
find it interesting that white
is so sure of his position he plays rook
b8
and not rook e8 check i think that's an
example of
great confidence
or maybe you know maybe he just doesn't
want to make a very big decision on the
48th move it's not like he was in time
trouble here sam had still 11 minutes on
the clock sometimes you just you just
postpone the big decision you take it to
the second time control you get extra 30
minutes then you think for a while and
then you pick up the right plan
exactly and i think that's a lot that's
a a skill that only comes with great
experience this idea of postponing a big
decision until after the time control a
lot of
class players amateur players will
not recognize that as a thing
but i think a lot of grand masters
they think it's just part and parcel of
being a strong player is knowing
when to postpone
uh a big decision like that rook v8 on
the board right and by the way another
team azerbaijan
azerbaijan we haven't looked at
any of their games they
originally they were going to come into
this olympiad as a top three team uh
unfortunately timor
uh rajab coming off a great showing
in the candidates
caught
kovit
and uh had to withdraw himself and
azerbaijan team azerbaijan fell in the
rankings yeah am i right archers to
number six positions yeah they they were
second seeded i believe they dropped the
number six so there was some unhappiness
right
members or at least one
other way they're really going to more
but i guess
sometimes these things happen and here
we have our
our top
10 uh this
nice to see norway as number three
poland number five azerbaijan number six
well i'm surprised that netherlands
at number seven is behind norway
netherlands has
usually always had a great
team
and we're very proud here in holland of
our underperformance
right it's a tradition for the dutch
to underperform
their ratings speaking about azerbaijani
match uh here uh they are currently
leading the match because i see that
they have scored three victories already
okay so it's 3-0 so far so rough
momentoff is playing the final game i
think so just a second if i if i didn't
see that oh no no no my mistake my
mistake okay announce the wrong result
no it's just one zero one zero it's the
next result it's the next one i was
looking at netherlands match where
indeed netherlands is up to zero already
no three zero very nice
uh
also it's nice to see england uh number
ten germany number nine and uh finally
just to round out the top ten always to
pay our respects to a team that's
so often
over performed ukraine
as often over performed
with their great stars at
did you ever get a chance to play um
with uh the seal yvonne chuck i think i
have played uh although not classical
time control games i believe one was
blitz another one was rapid or maybe
both racket
it was a long time ago so uh it was an
absolute pleasure to play against such a
legend
yeah
for for me you know a lot of times
people ask me you know who
were uh players that didn't become world
champions that you know you thought that
they might i it wasn't my opinion i
thought that the ceo would become world
champion but it was the opinion of gary
kasparov
who said yeah ivan chuck's going to be
world champion one day
i was like
gary's right
[Laughter]
so
it was a strange thing we all really
really really respected basil uh his
play there's no question he's a
phenomenal player it was the strange
thing that sometimes
during the big game
uh he
he he failed at the big moment right i
mean sometimes
you know people rise to the occasion and
become world champion
in a remarkable upset but it seemed like
he
the seal didn't
perform when he was supposed to when you
most expected him to outperform he
didn't
right
yeah that's right but i wanted to make
the comparison sorry i did it a little
too slowly
that
when
he's in a team competition
then ivan chuck is just like
bored one you know
know the dominating guy that you want
to play on the olympic team board one
the clevonchak and he just he just
destroys
uh his opponents
maybe since we're talking about ukraine
we could check how team ukraine is doing
here please uh so the top board today is
andre vela kitten uh maybe i could
also been a around for quite a long time
very very strong
very very strong player he i believe he
was up to 27 hunger recently he has
managed to recover his form because i
think he dropped to something like 2600
probably something that all of the chess
professionals can relate to at some
point you have ups and downs sometimes
you lose faith
right just cannot perform well one year
two years three years
for some people even longer and then you
get like a second chance you start to
play well again the rating goes up
i think also for uh for velocity and now
he's being showing some wonderful chess
recently and actually team ukraine is
winning the match at the moment at least
they're leading it one zero because
kirill chevchenko has beat his opponent
i see i see and
in this position it looks like white
is
about to play moves like bishop to b3
as well as c3
four
oh wait a minute
all right i'm pretty sure queen here
didn't happen right
uh hold on i think
i was expecting queen takes a7 yeah
right so maybe let's uh let's switch
back to samuel shankle's game against
junior dominguez because there's some
action going on
g4 yeah g4
as they say
in these positions when you have the
upper hand in in games you need to have
two weaknesses right according at least
our nymph switch
one weakness maybe isn't there a queen
side the second weakness on d5 some
people jokingly say that third weakness
is your opponent right
you cannot always rely on that
yeah
i've always relied upon people
with my opponent's weakness uh are you a
nims of the tran
um
i guess i'm supposed to because he is
originally from riga i mean of course
many people referred to him as a danish
player but he was
born in riga where i am right now i'm
bored
i'm not the wizard of riga yeah there
was of riga yeah sure so nimtovich
sometimes is uh attributed as a latvian
player
well i'm not really sure about that but
yeah he was born here so i guess that's
what matters exactly okay uh we won't
get into nimza for the moment because i
have very derogatory views of nimzovich
i thought he was a great for the
one-liners he had some absolutely
brilliant clips as
the pawn the past pawn is a criminal
that deserves to be under lock and key
and these these type the threat is
stronger than the execution so he had
some very very wonderful clips but i
thought he was just completely full of
nonsense
as far as his writings are concerned uh
great player uh by the way uh
we
if we could just go
over the last three moves we don't have
to go from the start but we left it
right that there was a doubling of the
rooks on the e-files so then they went
rook b8 rook e7 bishop f3 rook d7 g4
rook c7 okay
so if i
if i'm guessing right what sam intended
to do was play something like g4 g5
and
take away the f6 square from the black
king
i'm i'm not so sure i understand the
move g4 maybe archer you can explain why
did sam do
g mirage e4 you know that that really
beats me because when i'm looking at
this position i felt that in the all
classical way how you're normally
playing this we already discussed this
uh you you get away the king from e5 you
play king d4
maybe try to get the bishop on b3 and
somehow with f34 or something you
somehow snatch the pawn however
probably i mean most likely samuel had a
look at that he validated that it's not
so simple and he's seeking more targets
so with the idea of
this rook b8 he's postponing the
decision he activates the rook on bf
which is
rather annoying piece to care for black
and then he's seeking more targets for
example f x on g4 bishop takes on g4
suddenly this bishop is very active
right how do you how do you play there
for example something like rook c7 okay
there could be some tricks like i don't
know maybe even rookie 8 i'm not sure if
i have to do that
right
right and somehow i still get the king
on d4 i still might switch to these
ideas
bishop b3 or bishop f3 get to the pawn
on the e5 so i
i'm totally sure that he is following
the general idea to get to the pawn on
the e5 he's just
adding more things to the motion and
maybe
what he's doing at the king side he
treats is going to help him
intriguing uh it would i
i
wouldn't have taken that approach at all
myself i would have played rookie a
czech rook takes e6 i would have been
anxious and i mean with a capital a
to put my king on d4 and make sure that
the king on e5
never has uh
opportunities like
you know f5 f4 for example just to run
just to give one idea of what i don't
want to allow necessarily um
so okay a very very different uh
approach uh for me but uh i'm hoping
that uh
sam will enjoy and bring home
uh a victory in uh this game is white as
he does have an advantage
i just don't know how big it is
right maybe he'll have to switch to the
rocking game at our rookie game at some
point try the rooks both rooks put the
king on d4 maybe put the ball on g5
creating more weaknesses
okay not sure
i'm not sure about that
and by the way just to remind everybody
about our olympiad format obviously
we're in 11 rounds at one time the swiss
used to the the olympiad used to be a 13
round swiss i guess they felt that that
was a little bit long uh in terms of the
competition often times when it was 13
round swiss uh all the top teams had
played each other by the 11th round and
sometimes rounds 12 and 13 featured you
know team number one playing team number
30 you know because of the swiss system
and just how it worked
and uh there's
uh the time controls by the way just to
be very very uh clear
90 minutes plus 30 seconds and then you
get a second time control
of 30 minutes to finish the game
i believe most of the games already have
reached the second time control because
move 40 is when you get this extra time
so also samuel shanklin's game
kaz reached over 40 moves it's more for
the tree
um
right
so yeah i love it
rookie seven uh
the king
dropped back
king d6 was played in the game of sound
sorry
sorry right yeah king d6 is played here
so samuel here chose this trick again to
play rook e8
um after king d6 black doesn't take on
c5 i guess because of this internet so
uh
check on e7
right and um
right so now that the
second time control has started i wonder
i wonder what we could do now because we
haven't really
looked for a while at women's team let's
do it let's do it archers let's jump
over to the women's section
and uh
take us uh to our top seed if you will
yeah let's do that
and uh here the top seed is obviously
competing team india
and um conor compe
remember this italian game we looked at
yes some time ago now
according to my calculation black has an
extra piece
should be good right
very good
the extra piece
works for me
and uh any other results besides the
fact that uh
black is going to win this game um yeah
so black is going to win this game
also we have a lot of lot of results so
usually this is where uh a lot of
results come in end of the first time
control in average demons in supply 40
50 moves so
also we had a look at anna mozarchuk's
game against jesse february mozack
managed to score impressive victory
we
briefly talked about this at the start
um
i see a lot of a lot of very strong
players here not really
sure who to choose i could maybe
mention very quickly
is that john cy abdel malik from
kazakhstan managed to beat her opponent
obviously not a big surprise there she
was a bigila favorite
um
all right
do you have a preference yes sir which
game would you like to check which team
which country
um
sorry that i'm so nationalistic and
biased but
i i would love to see how the u.s
women's
ladies are doing keeping in mind i'm a
little bit surprised
by our
u.s
a little bit embarrassed uh because
of what we did on board one um
we have uh
a very good squad we're pleased with our
squad that uh biggum uh has uh taken
over arena crush's traditional
board one and we
begum is actually one of the lowest
rated players if not the lowest rated
player on our team it almost looks like
we're stacking
our team that's like what
so
i i'd be very very curious to see what
america is doing she already won the
game
wonderful
she already has won the game and also
arena crush has one car game
excellent on second border with a white
collar those are the results
check what else do we have here
ana zatonski on the third board is still
playing yep she's here playing the black
it's very traditional for anna i was the
women's team captain in baku
uh and if there was one player
in the whole tournament hall
of three thousand players
who would still be in the tournament
hall it was anna's house
heard games were never never ever short
and it seemed to to me that they lasted
until the very last uh move
right
i don't know why we have those types of
players but we do
but this is the final game of team
united states because
has won her game so team united states
is lady 3-0 off to a great start
great yeah nana here has a good position
with black
yes
she does so
very nice i see a team france has beaten
monaco
also 4-0 poland 3-0
georgia over iraq ukraine 4-0
and india
tajikistan
that's interesting uh 1-0
yep
a lot of a lot of disaster results um
maybe again let's go back to team india
what do you think that's fine and also
just to say to our audience
uh we'll do our very best if you guide
us
to a game or a
match
that you think really has a lot of
interest
right now
of
because it's day one and the various
transmissions if you would
keep your comments to the top ten teams
and the women's and the open we'll do
our best to uh address
uh any games that you might have knight
is on f5 what game is this one
and this is tanya sachdev's game from
team india and team india at the moment
is leading 2-0 because uh why charlie
and connor have won their games right
homie won as we saw she was going to be
at least she was right
um
kolkarni is still playing her game and
tanya sajda we still play her game and
here it actually seems that black is in
a lot of trouble he goes how do you get
rid of the spin on the bishop on h6
because normally you want to play
something like f6 during the queen but
it drops the bishop right probably queen
g6
yeah and i'm thinking queen g6 queen h2
and that's what i was saying about uh
grandmasters we just
so
so disliked being in these pins
at a certain moment black in order to to
escape this vicious bin is going to have
to do something as
bad as bishop to d7 captures f5
just in order
to
to be able to breathe
right
so i'm thinking after queen h2 i will
have to go queen f6
uh yeah so probably i should start with
queen f6 and say oh no i can't
because that
i might play f6 f7 pawn can you play f6
f6 yeah uh
wow um
no
no i i i
i'm okay i i'm just a little bit
reluctant uh i'm looking at b4
and after c4 i was
just thinking that the queen could go to
f2 and i'm like
queen could get stuck
maybe yes
you
immediately picked up on what i was
fearful about queen a7
or
yeah queen b6 and i and my queen on g6
i might not be able to be able to defend
uh
but this knight on f5 is a monster now i
think you're right i think you're right
indeed after queen g6 quinnish there
might be a move and actually also i
noticed what's even wrong with taking
because if you take it king g6 is
obviously a fork now after fx and g6
also this needs to be evaluated for
black because those are weaknesses which
are not going to go away for example
even 97 95 could be unpleasant
yeah
you could talk about a permanent
weakness
right there's one thing that black can
hang her hat on
for the moment at least is that white's
bishop on e2
is um
i want to say passive it's
and and there is a fear that if i do
play b4 and i miss time
my move b2b4 and my opponent shuts my
bishop out of the game
with c5 c4
that i'm crying that my bishop won't
play a role in the future so there is a
hope from black's point of view that she
might be able to create on a good day
some type of a fortress
right yeah definitely there's a room for
fortress of the queen g6 i think
uh the best chance for white to keep the
queens on the board yeah so such stuff
is suffering here and she's playing
against significantly low rated opponent
maybe doesn't mean a thing because not
everybody has access to so many
international tournaments we have seen
many underrated tournaments by the way
especially from india yes right i mean
they have a lot of sometimes 1800 level
players who play
amazing chess sometimes even crushing
grandmasters in open tournaments but
when the queen g6 happened it did happen
yeah queen takes g6
uh i
i would have thought queen h2
uh
maintaining that pin would have
i would have been frightened
uh to be black but now after takes 97
okay i
i have to play bishop to d7
or bishop to e8
she saw my idea but i didn't say it's
good
i mean you only took responsibility to
say look at this possibility
i mean
queen g6 but i'm not sure that's a good
idea i would love to keep the queens on
the board
variety of options right
well okay uh very very nice and
also in the top
uh ladies
we we saw anna
i just very quickly wanted to check the
remaining game of khaki kokarni i mean
before we move on
because it looks like white is just
completely winning this uh by the way
the the white king on g3 makes a very
beautiful impression i
can't say that she's in a bathtub but
it's a very nice pawn structure from
white
by the way talking about the bathtub for
those of you who are joined as late um
we were looking at a game of wesley sow
and you called this the bathtub
pawn structure
all right so we have to
eventually we have to look at what's
happening in the bath
yep yeah i think we are going to come
back to the ladies section at some point
later maybe or no
yeah maybe before before we switch on to
the open tournament maybe let's make a
short break because this is still the
second time control players get uh
additional 30 minutes on the clock
no time pressure at the moment so see
you in several minutes hope you like it
so far if you have some interesting
questions i get a again i said that
interesting questions well done
don't hesitate ask them in the chat stay
tuned and see you in a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
coach k says that when you first start
the game you look at that chess piece as
you you are the king on that board i got
this tattoo approximately a year ago i
got the kingpin my girl got a queen
piece
technically i'm really playing unless i
come to jail that's the only time i
really been playing a lot
we talk trash about who be who who
garbage if they give us a chance to play
with the man i most definitely
would
for me it was trying to give people
not just the skills in this really
interesting game
but so that the way they think changed
too all right so
in a week
mr squad behave
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad the most prestigious team
chess event on the planet
in chennai the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
a top three seed in the open and the top
seed in the women's section the host
country has legitimate reasons to
believe it can sweep gold
the united states are the top seed in
the open section
fabiano caruana and team usa have come
to chennai saddled with heavy
expectations of gold or bust
norway has never meddled at the olympian
led by the best player on the planet
magnus carlson leads a squad looking to
change all that
while medals count
some accomplishments won't be measured
in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste dosto
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that
let the games begin
welcome welcome back everybody we are
back live from the wall chess olympiad
in chennai india here you see the action
in uh tanya sajdev's game against
rukshana sadova
so one of the
leading
boards of team india were top seed in
the women tournament
a lot of fake starting action ahead
right so the second time control has
been reached your calls today are yasir
yasser is smiling right i i don't think
that was actually tanya's game i think
that that's a different i thought it was
game yeah
no i'm quite sure this is the game where
the queen was there's a king on g3
but uh it
it was a nice uh position for white
tanya's
game and white traded queens
and still an advantage but tanya i think
has great chances of saving that
position now going back for a moment i
saw that you had
a position there
of sam shankar
yep so he indeed he did try both rocks
both weren't something i was i was
thinking and now this inclusion of g4 g5
kelp skin
because that's potential third weakness
h5 maybe h takes maybe h6 it's
definitely h5 h6 are coming from white's
perspective so the idea is that as soon
as we can get our pawn to h6
in a very nice way
then we threatening instantly bishop h5
that's nice that's the that's the killer
and the yes
i guess it really depends where black
keeps bishop right so for that i guess
you want to play bishop c6
so that bishop h5 can be responded with
bishop e8
right exactly and i do believe that
black is going to discover himself
in a zooks one we don't play bishop h5
right away of course we play bishop h1
somehow we make a triangulation of not
exactly with the pawn on h6 i think
archers is it's a winning
uh strategy for white that in this exact
position you want it to be black's move
so
there you go
yeah
and
it's zuk's one
it's a tuk-tuk because now bishop b7 is
going to be bishop h5 this beautiful
idea you just mentioned bishop takes on
g6 right or g6 if black plays something
like bishop d7 or b8 protect against
that you just snatch the pawn on the e5
for free thank you exactly and if black
is supposed to move with the king for
example king e6 this gives away the c5
square which probably is a major loss
for black because the queen side falls
apart exactly the queen
indeed it's just it's that simple and
that fast
so uh
dropping the pawn in on h6 square i
think it's all a part of sam's long-term
strategy and
yeah he will just
zouzon his opponent
so about here
right this is about where we left it he
traded one row yeah the second rope
put put the pawn on g5 like king d4 he
already saw this from afar right they
should be technically winning exactly
what victor korchnoy would call the abcs
of chess and i'm seeing
from the camera shots at the playing
hall a lot of games
uh
seem to have been completed
right so do we have a lot of the results
in the open section already known i mean
for those of you who are joining as late
first of all shame on you second of all
shame on the vaughn
because he offered a draw from a losing
position and it was accepted nicely done
lavonne
did america give up anything more than a
half a point
um
no so it would seem
uh just the same with sam's game still
of course yeah the times game is still
ongoing
and um
maybe let's very quickly check
norway
wrong one
norway having dropped to half a point
there i just saw
yeah wales is down 2-0 okay and poland
leading 3-0
over syria
all right and uh as we're just going
through these results i see
azerbaijan uh that's what we're talking
about we always love hitting the
trampoline 4-0 is the start
jordan
is um
also lost three games to the netherlands
one game pending ukraine leading 2-0
over thailand uh germany leading 2-0
over the sudan england 2-0 over cyprus
so a lot of teams going for the big 4-0
but again usa getting dinged
so far a half a point and norway as well
so it was very very difficult
uh arthur said to make a 4-0 result
because
usually
somebody on the other side
has really prepared great
great preparation and one by uh
somebody's in trouble actually you know
lebron today had a good position after
the opening he made his very interesting
exchange sacrifice and then something
happened he started playing moves like
queen to d6 to b8 and
after this very uh pronounced and
exciting exchange sacrifice then king h8
to g8 he started wasting a lot of tempe
in my view
on moves that
actually were a step backwards so it was
strange from a very promising
position
he
he spoiled it there's no other way of
putting it
the win is a win and the entry in the
car points
not a perfect result that team united
states was hoping for
a small setback i wonder really what
it's going to mean for tomorrow's uh
bearings because
usually they're done
teams with four points are paired
against four points exactly or it could
be
some interesting complications there
no question about it and again a big
very big shout out to each and every one
of you for joining us and uh also do us
a favor tell your friends where you're
hanging out
and uh we promise that our coverage is
just going to get better and better as
we get deeper into the rounds we have a
lot of
profiles of the players and people in
india who are going to be giving us
great feeds and great
comments so
we
will show you for example a profile that
we created on the american team let's
have a look
with a couple of powerhouse countries on
the sidelines team usa is the popular
choice to take gold at the 44th olympiad
blessed with a talented roster led by
fabiano caruana the top-seeded americans
are looking to secure gold as they did
four olympiads ago back in 2016.
that gold medal was historic for the
united states as it was the first gold
for team usa since 1976
a drought that spanned across five
decades
loaded with olympiad experience caruana
and wesley so were both key contributors
to the gold medal team in 2016.
even one of the newest members to team
usa levon aronian is no stranger to
competing at the olympiad aronian bagged
gold while representing armenia during a
stretch in which that country won three
gold medals across four straight
olympiad appearances also making his
team usa debut in chennai is lanier
dominguez considered to be one of the
strongest players ever to come out of
cuba dominguez rounds out a team usa
roster with few weaknesses coached by
chess.com commentator robert hess team
usa's roster is so deep that reserve sam
shankland would likely play first board
for most countries in this year's events
as expected caruana leads team usa as
the first board
but even with a gold medal already under
his belt fabi heads into this olympiad
with plenty of motivation
coming off his clunky finish at the
candidates tournament fabi will need to
find his game for the u.s to realize its
potential as the favorites
during its triumph in 2016 team usa was
led in scoring by wesley soh
in this year's olympiad so returns to
play as the two seed which should offer
him some favorable matchups the three
seed is aronian which also should play
in team usa's favor
aronian ranked as the top player for
each of armenia's gold medals in 2006
2008 and 2012. aronia now brings that
experience and pedigree to team usa
while going up against the opposing
country's third best player
carrying three of the top-ranked players
at the 44th olympiad while facing a
significantly weakened field of
countries the united states is well
positioned to come away from india with
just its third gold medal since 1937.
the time for team usa is now
i wonder who wrote the script for that
profile by the way because there was a
wonderful work that got tossed in there
a clunky
performance at the candidates by fabiano
a clunky it's not very good in them
well it's usually a word
that is used to describe an automobile
whose engine is backfiring so
or something that's very weighty i i
never kind of thought of a player as
having a clunky result but okay uh nice
and by the way we do have uh
sam shanklin just played that all-star
move
h5h6
you might ask yourself what are you
doing
with the king side pawn pushing it to h6
you're setting up this
horrible
move bishop h5
so we were saying bishop to c6 a2 a3 our
turn and we called it zukzwang
basically black has no good move
in this position that doesn't worsen his
game it's bishop
the bishop cannot lead the d5 square
h5
right
and in the meanwhile
yeah bishop h5 is on tap
and sam shanklin looking to score
and what other uh
games have caught uh the interest of our
um
viewers i see another rook in game by
the way this is the game where you mean
looking at the couple of three times
maybe doesn't hurt to go back again with
it guarantee he's playing against makoto
rodwell
looking for this perfect score and he
has an extra pawn in the routine game
should be somehow technically winning
yeah because especially
the
black rook is extremely passive
uh
it's
playing the role of defender and am i
reading that right that white's last
move is rook on a6 to a5
6 ah because there was a pawn on c6 yeah
right how the bomb moved to c5 because
otherwise i was wondering why would you
play
that move but it was a pawn move that
then is it against some ghana fatsukswan
because i'm looking in this position i
wonder because black doesn't really have
many moves for example if i touch the
rook i need to protect the pawn on c5 so
if i play something like rook c6 there
might be rook a7 precisely h6
rook g7 or g6 precisely once again uh i
follow you completely and also just on
that note too i love
the move rook to david seven instead of
rook to g7 i love rook to d7 because
then i can put my rook on d5 so my rook
on a5 at this moment
it will attack the pawn on c5 but my
rook on d5
will not only
attack the pawn on c5 it'll also attack
the
fought on g5 and and push the black king
backwards so i think vedic is uh well on
his way
to uh securing a victory as well that's
a brilliant move indeed rook d7
yeah okay if not if not h6 then what or
rook c6 because
h6 is rook a6 now this is a weakness so
maybe it's a king move
can get five
okay
i could give a check i'm not sure if i
have to i guess i can't
it might be useful yeah
right and i'll play again go back black
is just running out of the moves
true
that's my feeling unless i'm missing
rook b7
and
ah in this case rook b7 does give you
rook
b
three check
it's a possibility
right some checks here i i'm thinking
instead of the move rook a6 uh i love
your idea of zuk's long archers play
rook b5
and say your turn oh that's nice yeah
just knock on the table your move black
ah but where do you move your rook or
where do you you go h6 just for
argument's sake go ahead and put h6 and
i go rook a5
ah like that i want the player would be
suspected rook a5 i guess is even
stronger just
just to once again emphasize that the
moment you move your rope then i want to
go rook to the seventh rank and to check
your king and then to
yes i think check check right away
after rook b6 just go ahead and check
and if the king goes back then you know
you start to harass the pawns yeah like
this
i like it i like it very much i also
like it looks very good
looks very very good uh
these rook endings oftentimes
it's about
patience be patient don't rush and let
your opponent after a move like rook a5
you can play rook b5 and
you don't need to rush everything in
good time
here's the thing and white is not
spoiling his position by playing rook b5
rook a5 black is on the position because
the rook on c7 has to stay it needs to
connect the seventh fret needs to play
the pawn on h7
right
and just kind of like that sam shanklin
position every time you touch your king
and you go
king f6 and allow king e4 or if you go
king d6 and allow king e4 king f5
uh it's
it's it's all going uh white's way
very very nice
again i just want to give a big shout
out to the playing to india and the host
country in the playing all because more
and more as i'm looking at the camera
work
uh and the players at the board and
the chairs are wonderful the tables look
good
the playing hall looks spacious
and i remember the playing hall in
calvia
it was terrible it was i mean it was too
cramped
it was just
too too too small and here it looks like
uh with very very short notice the
indians are putting on a splendid
uh olympia
indeed indeed they have they have done
it usually that other countries do in
several years yes they have done it in
such a quick time frame it's just coming
exactly it's a real
real challenge and i remember just so
many of olympiads that was just getting
visas
uh visas are
trust me what i tell you
their major effort and so many countries
uh so many uh people from different
countries have visa issues
and just to get a hundred and i want to
say 85 i don't know what exactly is the
number to get that many countries teams
uh proper visas that
that's some serious work
i imagine a lot of logistics yes
uh also just to mention of course russia
and china are not at this olympiad
and that's just the way it is uh but i
do see in chat whereas china china had
obviously a lot of coveted
restrictions and there was just a lot of
things that prevented
them from participating they're
definitely missed both in the open as
well as the women's section
all right
well yes sir is there a game next you'd
like to check
uh in fact i've been following you
and uh i've been following our chats too
so if there is something out there in
the top 10
that we haven't spotted or well the deer
chat says david cowell is in trouble
david howell let's jump to england
no we can't join them
he's in trouble
i don't know is this
is this doesn't seem like a trouble to
me
why would this be trouble just a second
okay white has space but black has an
extra pawn right
no it looks good to me
two five six no
uh i used to play uh in my career um
the cambridge springs
uh defense against the queen's gambit
declined and oftentimes my opponents
wanted to punish me
and they would
sacrifice upon
for great development
and so forth and so on and if i ever
neutralized
their
advantage in time that is to say their
development the extra pawn
won the day and in my view it's quite
the opposite i think that uh black is
doing just fine here
and after a move for example like a7 a5
by no means the only move
uh i would prefer
black's position because i think the
game just stopped receiving moves to be
honest
yeah i i i think the move d4 d5 would
just result in you know
a cleaning of the position and black
will be very happy at the end of the day
it's like the tide goes out there's
there's no advantage for white what
white should do on the other hand
is not that easy and if i was in white
shoes i'd start thinking about g4 h4 g5
and just hoping
[Laughter]
that i could make pretensions
all right
um
ah we have a question from
uh
the chat what's the question there what
led to the change in the olympiad in
that the top-rated players often used to
play but now they all are that's the
question
ah
um
i think one of the
biggest things
was
that
the olympiads
used to be
um
how do i put this a bit in the nice way
uh the olympiads were not good events
they were simply not
good events they were very very long i
already mentioned that that there was 13
rounds now very 11.
uh but they used to be much much longer
than that they they had uh these
qualification round robin
sides they had
these events
would last a month or two
a lot of the federation simply didn't
have the resources to support a strong
team
so a lot of uh the top players didn't
want to
invest one month a play or even two
months of play
for an event that didn't really pay
that's to begin that's just kind of like
stop right there
but
i want to say
that more or less from the 70s onwards
the olympiads really started to become
much more prestigious events right and
federations started to invest
in their teams
the
host nations also
uh the budgets began to get bigger and
bigger and bigger
so that really a lot of the uh
the nations like for example turin
in italy or tromso in
norway had government support like
torino in 2006 came just shortly after
the olympics
in uh
uh
italy and the olympic village is
actually where the players were hosted
like they had all of these rooms that
was
a follow on
from the olympics so i just wanted to
say that the olympics themselves just
became a lot more prestigious events a
lot better supported by national
federations
and
uh the players started to really
appreciate them not just for the
competition and winning gold medals but
like i said earlier this
opportunity to meet organizers to meet
people across the world and it became a
really a friendly
event rather than
a harrowing journey
to god knows where you are going to end
up what position do you have you have a
position
i was just browsing through the games
which is still ongoing
i'm curious if we have to follow
how
where did santosh
he's gonna win his game
yes because that's pretty much
the only remaining game from the top
boards right
it sure looks to me like the position
that you have up uh
there uh bartel with that uh
wonderful two two minor pieces that
should be winning for white i would
i would expect white to win that game
so it was seen from
i guess rook d8 rook d8 to sure
man every fiber in my being
demands rook d8 be played as soon as
possible
i wrote david is on the board yeah same
move faster was better
so maybe again we can jump back to the
women's section alrighty
let's do it since there's not so many
games left here an open section maybe
there's something really exciting going
on there
tanya such sachdev is still
fighting
lips don't look so bad now anymore
right she had this very difficult
king-side
pawn structure that was this long-term
static weakness
but now they look like they're just
equally matched on the king's side she's
also tanya has uh activated her dark
square bishop put it all the way down
there to f2 maybe it will go to even
this where you
and maybe she is the one who is the
ambitious player
she starts to think about it because
well i think the position is
going to be a draw whether white plays
the move b3 or not but i think tanya has
really right at the ship when we saw her
an hour ago
boy that there was a white knight on the
f5 square and that was an unassailable
piece i have to go back to that moment
really yeah just yeah it was just so
good for white we expected queen h2
to land on the board and
ask tanya how are you ever going to drop
break the pin on the h file
her opponent
traded on g6 and the next thing you know
we got the current game position the
pawn capture
this was not a good choice right right
yeah and
tanya
very
very acute and accurate play
brought her king to c5 or bishop to f2
and as you said who's playing for the
win
i think black defense out of the danger
here right
there's no risk for her to continue
maybe before maybe just wait for a while
right
but the problem from black's point of
view like imagine white
just
playing
poorly uh king c1 king c2 king c1 i
never do anything
what can you do you can put your pawn to
b3 if you're light you could play b5 b4
b3
but then your king will never
uh
cross
any
any there's no way of
black's king getting into the white camp
so you can't really play the move d3 the
best you could do
is capture on c3 and then
in that kind of a world
your king is kind of
stuck
to the defense of the c4 pawn
you would be you're right yeah you were
there probably gonna be totally a draw
yeah you would therefore have to play
bishop takes d2
and then you can imagine king takes d2
and you can get your king all the way to
b3
but then you don't go any further the
king stays on d2 and white oscillates
with her bishop between f1 and fb2 so
really it feels like the draw is
a virtual guarantee
anonymous antonski still play for united
states yes
they're going to continue for a while
i know i know my honors
and honest onski
if there's ever a player like i said who
will be the last to lead the tournament
i don't know some
some people have that gift i don't know
archer if you're one of those uh people
who play to the
to the empty hall
i used to be
yes but i don't have the patience
anymore really does that you have the
sits flash
no i used to be really really this
annoying quality
to play very long games right but i
can't endure playing so long games
anymore i mean sometimes this happens
like recently i mean the previous grand
swiss i was playing with david cobble
an eight-hour game
oh no
eight hours how is that eight-hour game
i was i was just knocked out i mean just
so i
couldn't even comprehend what's
happening here what is morning what is
evening it was very very tough
so
yeah i can i can relate to that
but not not often really but i i really
want to emphasize to our audience
when you start talking about an
eight-hour game so i just had an
eight-hour flight
it was atlanta
to
uh amsterdam
and you know during this flight they
serve you two meals it's a dinner and a
breakfast right
but if you're working eight hours at the
chessboard you're not having a dinner
and a breakfast or you're not having any
meals so
this ability to play these long games is
like something extra special because
also you need energy
archers and
you can destroy your result in the
future as well
this is what happened actually destroyed
my entire tournament
oh
no energy left yeah i made a draw but
after that
poof
[Music]
my goodness uh that's why you know
the computers have basically said you
know you can't play germans anymore
because
uh you know here's best play and all you
have to do is memorize light
but
i want to say that uh we used to play
five hours and that was a very
challenging period and then you just
went to dinner you stopped the game and
you resumed it the next day and that was
somehow rather civilized you know
five hours of play and uh adjournment
and you
and that's just the way it was
eight hours in a row
that's a bit tough right ah
yeah
and
because also
and again this is something i really
want to emphasize for our audience
you
have worked really really hard you
prepared yourself very well
you
somehow
you tricked your opponent
you have an advantage yes
the much wanted advantage out of the
opening
and you played it very well to a bigger
advantage in the middle game
and then your opponent resourcefully is
defending in the ending
and all you need is one bad move
and everything is destroyed
you play
you play an eight-hour game
your chances of making a mistake
increase exponentially how we made three
you made turns yeah yeah with every half
hour that passes so
those
long long long games or a measure of
endurance that's it yeah but by talking
about about that it's really amazing
that some players really specialize on
that they are very good at playing long
games like anna you said yes for example
david cavallo mentioned he is also used
to play very long games and this is
where really the physical stamina the
endurance you have it plays a role
because i do believe that
some players
don't crack
after i mean some players crack after 30
moves some crack crack after 40 after 50
after 70. well
some players need to be broken for seven
hours
right and that's a nice way of putting
it but yes i follow you yeah and then it
becomes incredibly incredibly physically
difficult to play so yeah it's a it's a
big skill it's a big skill definitely to
keep the game going and going and going
yeah and what you just said about the
stamina that was another thing that i
think these modern uh players these
modern grandmasters do have
as a skill set that's really required by
the
disciplines of today
is
you do have people like magnus carlsen
like fabiano they go to the gym
daily and they do work out they they
realize that their cardiovascular
their physical
energies have to be rather high and if
you look at some of these
photos of these old guys you know like
the legends of chess the bent larsons in
the world if you will
they were portly they weren't in the
best of shape uh
and i think today you just need to be in
really good shape because of the
physical demands that are upon you i
mean and also talking about the long run
right it's just not one game
sometimes you're playing a long
tournament like the olympia i mean here
we have 11 rounds
yes which is played in how many days is
it 12 13 days there's almost no rest day
there's preparation right it's it's
tough i mean i still remember yasser the
was just olympia in baku
uh where i was playing for team latvia
yeah it was one of the toughest
experiences of my lifetime
because it was
evening prep
for the players um then there's the rest
breakfast morning prep
dinner
game five six hours
rinse and replace every day every day
dinner evening prep rest morning prep
yeah a lunch go to the game evening prep
et cetera it's just non-stop it's
nonstop
so it's it's very tough i mean some
players maybe go to the olympia too
you know to enjoy the atmosphere but
when you're going to be really
competitive it
it's really asking you
to bring out everything you have
yes and then no question and everything
you just said
to that i can add that
if you go back to the 80s they had
adjourned game days uh the days that
were just devoted to a germans and those
are germans
took more out of you than today's prep
what do i mean by that
you and i are going to play tomorrow
and you look at my games with white and
you say okay yasser is going to play
d4c4
and against the king's indian or the
grunfeld he's going to play this system
or that system and you prep
but you're guessing you're guessing your
your experience your guesswork is pretty
good but you can't be
100 sure you're going to have
such and such a position a germans were
completely different animals
you knew exactly this is the position
this is the position and from here we're
going to go here here here here here
here and so suddenly your adjourned game
analysis
was really
uh i want to say
focused
focused and i see we've got tanya by the
way
we've got her position on the board this
is the position that we thought
uh
was going to be a draw
i would all of what i was just saying
was leading up to i remember uh in my 60
memorable games bobby fischer versus
michael vodminik and the soviets
uh having their adjourned game analysis
that in many ways rewrote history
that game was so crucial for the
olympics and crucial for bobby and bobby
we do have b4 now on the board
yeah again i just did right yeah i don't
see if white just goes king d1 king c2
and just ignores every
pretension that black can make
nothing to be done well sometimes when
you can't do things you rely on your
opponent yeah this is always something
you can do
maybe white is going to take it
you know
right right then it gives you some axis
squares
that is true that is true you can
blunder
that kind of uh a capture and open up uh
avenues for tanya's king so actually you
know this could be not so easy i mean
depending on the player really i don't
know much about the white player here
exactly allowing the pawn on b3 it looks
scary
and you have to like evaluate deeply
that in the end the passive defense
holds right yeah by the way
besides the passive defense is the move
b
to b 3
ridiculous or is that which move
no oh black plays b4 congratulations
tanya
white plays
b3 b2 b3
surprise
uh
and says i don't want to play passive i
want to be
i want to be an active player i want to
play bishop take
c4 and yeah go ahead take that guy and
bishop takes c4
oh that's
very complicated no
well i'm hoping to get a bishop's
opposite color ending that's not
complicated right
but if you take my knight i was going to
take the bishop on
e6 and say there's no way that you're
going to
kick my king out of d1
i make an easy draw so i was wondering
can white
actually essay
this uh
move b
to b3
it looks reasonable it does doesn't it
maybe maybe for black the final chance
is try to do something like this run
with the king to e3 a2 or f3 the d2 is
hanging the pawn on d2 might be
protected yes that's a minor problem
then
yes exactly and then i go bishop f7 and
i put my king on d1 immediately of
course and that's it and that's it i
closed the door maybe i played b4 and
just remind you hey wait a minute you
know
i got a passer too
but anyway uh the move b2b3 just
you were mentioning the pass of defense
and i said well what if actually white
plays b3 and plays active
yep so b3 definitely is a move doing
nothing is a move
i'm pretty sure that
not upon his move
and bishop one is a move
probably even c dex doesn't lose
but i mean i think given the
circumstance of syrix on
it's probably the worst of the choices
it's the worst choice yeah
by the way i'm saying in our chat that
time has spent 15 minutes on the move
b4b
b5 b4 is that true
that's
that's a lie she's down on the clock to
two minutes
whoa
not really a time trouble i guess
because there'll be 30 seconds 30
seconds per move exactly
right
and by the way archers i'm kind of
kicking myself i i actually had a very
busy schedule of late
i was doing the grand chest for uh in a
genre
but
i'm regretting that i miss
this moment to visit india because i've
never visited india and i've always
wanted to how about you have you managed
to
uh visit india in your career never i've
never been there
and i already said it i saw some of the
pictures from opening ceremony
the hospitality
the playing card
yeah i wish i was there exactly i i'm
having regrets i mean this is me i get
my reasons why i decided not to go there
this year but um
yeah now of course i mean it looks
really great
and so all i can do is
uh wish team latvia that they're going
to perform well
yeah
so
right
yeah and i i i was speaking with fishy
but she had invited me says you gotta
come to chennai and i'm like i invite
you
how do you refuse this
with some of the indians like sarah
nicole i think it was during the french
team championships in france early in
june and we played a game
uh it was a draw and after the game we
had a chit chat he asked are you coming
to the olympiad
i said no he said why not
why not and this question had like a lot
of emotion like him and how how can you
not come to chennai right this is the
right i went of the year basically
everybody's going to chennai and even
nigel short tweeted
i think it was yesterday if you're not
in chennai you're not a chess player
wow slap
slap
yeah nigel
making me feel worse
definitely made me feel worse
[Laughter]
nice
so after b4 do we have any moves
thereafter so um now let me refresh
no no no no wait
actually
i don't physically kept before on the
board
for some reason
i'm looking at the cameras it's
hard for me to tell
it could be a relayer
how about
oh this is the game that it looks like
he's uh
ready to
rock and rumble with rook to d5
and that's going to just be a killer how
about sam
uh
shankland uh for the probably already
monarchy's game like an hour ago but he
did i think so i mean
right that was that nice
zug's wong moment sometimes
yep
a2 a3 on the board wow
his opponent assembly resigned
yes
he definitely was well familiar with the
concept of the zhuksvank yep
he saw what was coming bishop h5
and or a2 a3 nice game did it not so
many not so many games ongoing
no
i'm not really sure very empty there
right not sure which game to choose
maybe
um
maybe the second india theme could be
interesting to check
if we have the relay is not uh
not
certain
if we have the relay right
this is not very clear is it no
i think there's some rules missing as
well out of bishop c7
because the minor pieces the
white are keeping black's king
essentially at bay
it's almost like a an invisible
shield black's king can't go to d7 to d6
to d8 it can't approach and escort the
pawns so the pawns aren't going to win
the game by themselves
not when fights knight is on this great
score c5 and not easily
pushed away now the question is can
white win well
the white king would presumably have to
get to d5 and
push the black knight into some
inactivity
i don't know i i i feel that while
white's um
ahead from the material point of view
it's not so easy for white to win this
game you're taking i think we're just
missing a lot of moves to be honest
because this was move 46
ah you think a relay i think so i think
so
clock shows zeros
unless he lost some time
right i don't think this happened and
india's second team has been leading so
far 3-0 okay
so
by the way
the cash one and also sidwani won his
game
at tip to spain uh they did defeat uh a
welsh
team 4-0
i thought uh somebody on wales was going
to nick
a half a point or more but
they were not able as spain goes for a
zero
sheriff won his spectacular game
we left it
at some point here queen h3 that was how
uh alexi
uh managed to bring his queen i said f1
was a terrible square
and it was
but uh h5 was much better and it looks
like
ah new scoresheet holy slowly he
approached oh queen e4 look at that
what a lovely finish queen bridge
yeah and rook d8
we were we were saying the opera game
and uh the paul morphe opera game with
rook the eight mate the same thing
yeah
alexi uh
achieved uh immortality
and right okay maybe let's make a quick
break yes sir yeah that works for
something like several minutes then we
can round up what's got what's been
happening here so far
uh don't go anywhere
i see you soon okay
deal
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
um
we just played like three games it's a
four to one streak my way
me and him actually learned around the
same time
you know it's been fun watching him grow
he's early on two treasures tweeting off
too he doesn't mind losing his queen but
he uses his horses more i'll be i'm a
little mad you take my horses
they the deadliest piece on the board
everybody thinks it's the queen but it's
the horse because
you can't defend it
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the chess olympiad from
chennai india
we are having a lot of fun on our first
day of broadcast but i gotta say archers
uh all good things have to come to an
end and soon it's just about the results
yeah let's maybe check let's maybe check
some of the results of the round one and
some small upsets did happen but of
course the favorites mainly won their
matches
for sure uh
everybody wants a four zero result not
so easy to achieve
even the mighty and much vaunted usa
team got nicked for a draw
there by angola and before you say
nick for a draw it could have easily
been a loss right as one lavone aronian
offered to draw from a losing position
it was accepted uh and then you see
germany has won four as zero
as well
here you see some other results
azerbaijan 4-0
netherlands is 3-0 up against jordan
wow ukraine 3-0 i guess one game is
still ongoing yeah germany 4-0 over
sudan not a big surprise and england is
about to score a clean victory over
cyprus
exactly and we were seeing in the
background there because so many games
look like they've been uh completed we
were seeing a tanya
uh such as a position from the women's
section and i wonder if we've got a lot
of the results of the women uh
to mention as well
also big
shout out to our team in india who are
relaying us so many of the games the
positions
they have put together something very
special of highlights of this day one so
when
arters and
uh when archer and i
uh do sign off do
not uh sign off yourselves but stay
around hang around on the twitch stream
as we will be presenting
uh the highlights and that will come up
much later but i just wanted to give a
warning
to everybody that we have
we've got some good stuff
uh coming your way don't you leave don't
you don't you dare
yeah and also to all of those of you who
join our broadcast thank you very much
for uh sharing your day with archer and
i uh but also
you can help us a lot by telling your
friends
where you're gonna hang out and uh we've
got a schedule uh coming up uh for each
and every round and you can follow us
uh we will be here you and i
uh for the first three rounds right
archer yep first three rounds i believe
um for the some of the next rounds as
well every single day the action starts
the same time except the final round 11
30 central europe in summer time or if
you are at the pacific coast okay you'll
have to wake up early 2 30 a.m
not to miss the start of
every new round in olympia every single
day is a new round in the olympiad
there's couple of rest days but total 11
rounds one round per day that's the
schedule
exactly and then they break for august
4th will be the first and only free day
i mean after all you've got to make the
bermuda party possible right our turn i
think so
august 3rd will feature the bermuda
party we will not be there to call it
i'm afraid that's you can watch the
video
but yeah maybe we'll watch it on video
there you go that's a good i'm not the
same right not the same uh
you miss the uh
the
the dark and stormy cocktails um but yes
uh one free day and
as i understand it there's going to be a
lot of team commentary as well not just
ourselves
right
all right all right it's been an amazing
day first round some technical issues
from the start some games were missing
we caught up in the end
after some minutes in
so
yeah it's been exciting day some small
minor upsets still the favorites won
their matches
uh team united states team india
and uh i guess this is where we say
goodbye but like yasser said we do have
something special prepared for you
exactly before we do say our final
goodbyes uh a warm uh shout out to you
arters uh it's been uh very very nice
for me to make your acquaintance
and to uh work alongside you i've
enjoyed the day i look forward to
tomorrow as well
thank you likewise i'm wonderful and as
archer says as we close down and we
thank you all for watching
do enjoy this very special this nice
special that's coming up tomorrow
[Music]
so
you